AND WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR.
TUESDAY MAY THE FOURTH WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
CAN START. AS A SUB COMMITTEE
WHICH WE WILL DO AND I LIKED
EVERY WELCOME EVERYONE HERE AND
RECOGNIZE THE. TECHNICAL SORT
OF ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
COVETED PANDEMIC STILL GOING ON.
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BOTH HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM ADD. THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL MASKS ARE REQUIRED
WHILE IN THE BUILDING. AND WE
HAVE SOME. BIG WE HAVE ROOM FOR
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS UP
HERE IF WE DON'T THEN THERE MAY
BE SOME DOUBT IN THE AUDIENCE
WE HAVE LIMITED ROOM FOR PUBLIC
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF STAFF IN
THIS ROOM. AND CHAIRS ARE
MARKED OUT TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE DISTANCING WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR.
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
EITHER IN THIS ROOM. WHICH IF
YOU'RE HERE AND WANT TO SPEAK
ON AN ITEM. PLEASE JUST
INDICATE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I'LL ASK YOU TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WE ASK THAT NOBODY
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE SO THAT IT
REMAINS CLEAN AS POSSIBLE. WILL
SERVE WITNESS TESTIMONY STATION
ON THE NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL THAT IS OPEN TO ANYONE.
WHO DOES NOT WANT TO COME INTO
THE HEARING ROOM. OR INTO THE
CAPITAL BUT PROVIDE SOME
TESTIMONY. AND THEN FINALLY OF
COURSE MOVE WE DO GET MOST OF
OUR TESTIMONY COMMENTS ON THE
TELEPHONE. WE DO OF TOLL FREE
NUMBER WHICH IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IT SHOULD
BE SHOWING ON YOUR SCREENS FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING.
IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE THE ACCESS
CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR. TWO OH TWO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO AND WHEN YOU DIAL IN.
PLEASE ISLAND WHEN THE BILL IS
FIRST BROUGHT UP TO BE HEARD
AND THE OPERATOR WILL HELP YOU.
GET INTO THE QUEUE TO BE ABLE
TO. MAKE YOUR TESTIMONY WE ARE
INDICATION OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ANY PARTICULAR
BILL. SO THANK YOU I THINK THAT
DOES IT WITH THAT LET'S START
WITH OUR FIRST ITEM ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB SEVEN FORTY SIX MISSOURI.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FOUR SIX. ASSEMBLY ILL
SEVEN FOUR SIX WILL CODIFY THE
ELIMINATION OF AMERICA MINIMUM
MARRIAGE REQUIREMENT INTO LAW
THAT APPLIES TO ALL COUPLES
SEEKING A STEP PARENT ADOPTION.
AND ENSURES THAT PARENTAGE LAWS
REFLECTING FURTHER PROTECT OUR
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE.
HISTORICALLY SAME SEX COUPLES
ARE MET WITH MORE OBSTACLES TO
BECOME ADOPTIVE PARENTS IN
COMPARISON TO THEIR
HETEROSEXUAL COUNTERPARTS
ADOPTION HAS NOT BEEN EASY FOR
THE LGBTQ I A PLUS COMMUNITY.
FOR MANY DECADES LGBT Q. ARE A
PLUS COMMUNITY HAS BEEN BANNED
FROM ADOPTING CHILDREN EITHER
DUE TO LEGAL BARRIERS BECAUSE
OF DISCRIMINATION OR THE MULTI
LAYERED PROCESS MANY GO THROUGH
TO HAVE CHILDREN. OUR CURRENT
LAWS ARE ALLOWING MANY FAMILIES
TO ENCOUNTER EXPLICIT- COVERED
DISCRIMINATION WHEN THEY
ATTEMPT TO FILE FOR ADOPTION
THIS PROCESS SHOULD NOT BE
CHALLENGING BUT RATHER SEAMLESS
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES MANY
PROTECTIONS FOR NON BIOLOGICAL
PARENTS WHO HAVE BEEN ADOPTED.
BUT MANY STATES DO NOT THIS IS
WHY EXPEDIENCY IN THE PROCESS
IS IMPORTANT. OUR LAWS DO NOT
PROHIBIT COURTS FROM USING
THEIR DISCRETION TO AT A
MINIMUM ARRIAGE PERIOD COUNTY
WIDE BEFORE COUPLES CAN TAKE A
STEP PARENT ADOPTION. THE
MISALIGNMENT OF EXPLICIT
PROHIBITION HAS LED TO
CONFUSION AND AMBIGUITY IN
PRACTICE. SAM IS GOING TO THE
STEP PARENT ADOPTION PROCESS
ALREADY ENCOUNTER A CONFUSING
AND COMPLEX SYSTEM WITH STATE
AND COUNTY POLICIES THAT VARY
ACROSS THE STATE WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WE REMOVE BARRIERS THAT
HINDER AND PROLONG THE PROCESS
FOR FAMILIES ESPECIALLY LGBTQ I
A- PLUS COUPLES WHO. EXPERIENCE
PERVASIVE BARRIERS AND THE
ADOPTION PROCESS WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS MY WIFE
COURTNEY CERVANTES DOWNS AND
GABRIEL MALDONADO EXACTED
DIRECTOR OF TRAVELERS XIN.
THANK YOU SO WILL FORCE GO TO
COURTNEY CERVANTES DOWNS AND
THEN TO GABRIEL MALDONADO BOTH
ARE WITH US. ON THE TELEPHONE.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR VICE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS COURTNEY CERVANTES
DOWNS AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
AB SEVEN FORTY SIX OTHER MOTHER
THAT IT'S CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF ADOPTING MY FIFTEEN
MONTH OLD TRIPLETS I KNOW FIRST
HAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
PARENTS FACE WHEN GOING THROUGH
THE ADOPTION PROCESS. ONE OF
THOSE CHALLENGES BEING THE
REQUIREMENT OF MARRIAGE ONE
YEAR PRIOR TO THE BIRTH OF A
CHILD. MY WIFE AND I IN YOUR
EAGER TO EXPAND OUR FAMILY
AFTER MARRIAGE ARE POPPING
PARENTHOOD LOVE TOOK OUT THE
MOST TWO YEAR. FROM START TO
THE BIRTH OF ARTS. BUT THAT IS
NOT THE CASE FOR EVERYONE. I
WILL TALK ABOUT MY ADOPTION
PROCESS AND RIVER COUNTY. I
THINK THAT WE FIVE INDIVIDUALS
THE- ALL THE- AND ALL OF THEM
HAD THE SAME PER STATEMENT. FOR
YOU YOUR WIFE LEAGUE MARRIED AT
LEAST ONE YEAR PARTS THE TRUMP
BURKE. BECAUSE OF WERE NOT
YOU'RE NOT ELIGIBLE ADOPT. THAT
AMY TOOK ME BACK TO THE START
OF OUR JOURNEY PARIS. WHATEVER
CHILDREN WOULD HAVE BEEN BORN
BEFORE HITTING OUR ONE YEAR BUT
IN ANNIVERSARY WHAT I NEVER BE
CONSIDERED ARE RECOGNIZED AS A
LEGAL PARENT. ANY OF YOU ARE
PARENTS OR CAREGIVERS THAT I'M
SURE YOU UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
ENSURE TO. ENSURE THAT YOUR
CHILDREN ARE ALWAYS IN SAFE
HANDS AND SECURED. CAN YOU EVEN
IMAGINE HAVING TO ADOPT YOUR
OWN CHILD. THAT IS A REALITY
AND THE L. G. B. T. Q. I. A.
PLUS COMMUNITY. AND CALIFORNIA
MY FAMILY FULLY PROTECTED IT
AND I AM RECOGNIZED AS AN EQUAL
PARENT. TO MY WIFE BUT THAT IS
NOT THE CASE IN OTHER STATES.
AND COUNTRIES. THAT IS WHY WE
DO. TO CONFIRM MY PARENTS
THROUGH THE LEGAL FIRST. BY
POPPING AB SO FOURTH. AND A
LEMONADE THE- BARRIERS TO
TOPICS. IT PROVIDES CLARITY TO
THE COURT. WHAT THE FEAR OF
BEING. TWENTY EXPAND THE FAMILY.
AND PUT A- STAMP ON ONE A
FAMILY DESPITE THE HAVES. ARE
YOU. ASK TO PUT YOUR- IN MY
SHOES AND THEN IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THAT ARE. IN FEAR. THERE'S TO
HAVE LEGAL. WE EQUALLY FOR. ALL
OF OUR FEES. AND I CAN. TO
BARRIERS TO A- I YOU OR TIME
AND HAVE A- TO SPEAK REGARD AB
SEVEN PERFECT. THANK YOU N.
YOUR BILL. YEAH GOOD MORNING MR
BY HERE THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE-
MY NAME IS MALL AND I THIRD THE
FOUNDER AND THE OF TRUE OF
POLLUTION WE ARE COMING HEALTH
ALSO JUSTICE OR- SERVING ME IN
THE EMPIRE EVERY AND AMBER YOU
KNOW COUNTY. I AGREE TO THIS
MORNING WITH MY INTO. IN THE
FOR A SEVEN SIX NOW ONLY AT THE
EXACT DIRECTOR AT THE L. G. B.
AT. BUT AT THE GAME AND COLOR
MY- I WRECKED. THE VITAL THAT
THAT BIT PLEDGES. HAS AN
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND-
OF OUR- MOST BONE. ARE KILL.
AND AS WE BEGIN TO A NATION TO
HIM BY UPON JOURNEY PULLING OF
COUNTRY THRILLED OUT OF POVERTY.
COOL THANK YOU GUARDIANS AND
BAM. WILL BE AT THE- OF THE
MISSION. AND AS LGBT Q. YOUTH
ARE. DIFFICULT IN BY DISCRETE.
HELP THAT. BY LAND EXTREME
SOCIAL POLICE. NOT ONLY THAT.
MEANING YOU PUT THE LEAGUE
RIGHT VOTE DOT. WILL BE I FIND
IT. IF EAT ADDRESS PEOPLE LGBTQ.
AND NOT. CHILL WHO ARE WITHOUT
GUARDIAN. IN AMERICA IN THE
STATE OF. I LEGISLATURE NOT
ONLY READ. IN THE IN THAT IN
THE STEP IN THE- FOR. PARENTS
BUT ALSO WILL BE YOU TO THE TO
RISK TO THEM NEEDS INCLUDING
PROPERTY. HOMELESSNESS AND
HEALTH. AFFECTING YOU CAN STATE
OF. WHO REQUIRED. LOVE THE
HUMAN DIGNITY AND FAMILY. I AM
STILL BAFFLED I WOULD MAN BACK
IN THE DAY AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WE ARE STILL PUTTING FORTH
LEGISLATION IN SEEKING THE
HUMANIZATION AND WRITE THEM ALL
PEOPLE. AND A PRACTICE AS OLD
AS THE DOCTRINE. I LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS IN A BIG THE DID LONG
AGO. BUT HERE WE ARE TODAY AND
I APPLAUD IT BY PER DAY ABOUT
BUSINESS OF READING THE
INEQUITY ACCESS THAT STEP
PARENT THAN DOMESTIC. HAVE
ADDED DOT AND BEING ABLE TO
ZERO DEBT. SO I DO YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I HOPE YOU. HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT AB. SEVEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU N. THIS THERE'S-
AMENDMENTS LISTED UP FIVE
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE IS AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS. YES CENTER CAN AS
ON AMEND GREAT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTS IS THE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM TESTING STATE WHO WOULD
LIE TO IN. A FOR A SEVEN FORTY
SIX. SEEING NONE TO WITNESS THE
ROOM. SEEING THE RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN ALLOW FOR THE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO OF FOR A
SEVEN SIX AT THIS WE'RE TAKING
NAME A FILL. AND SO. YOU MISTER
CHAIR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ENTER A PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR IT DOES NOT APPEAR
THAT THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IT
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU I.
THOUGHT AND THEN I DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION LISTED SO IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEE NON
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN FORTY SIX. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPEARS THAT NO ONE IS SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THEN YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES OPERATOR
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE
THE CERVANTES YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB SEVEN
FOUR SIX WILL AGAIN CODIFIED
THE ELIMINATION OF A MINIMUM
MARRIAGE REQUIREMENT INTO LAW.
THAT APPLIES TO ALL COUPLE
SEEKING A STEP PARENT ADOPTION
AND ENSURE THAT PARENTAGE LAWS
REFLECT AND FURTHER PROTECT ALL
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON A. B. SEVEN
FOUR SIX THANK YOU AND WE WILL
TAKE A MOTION ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU. RIGHT MR FOR
A. THREE FIFTY EIGHT. A RATED
NUMBER TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- BEFORE I
BEGIN I WAS STATE I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. AB THREE
FIFTY EIGHT WILL WOULD DEFINE
IT WHAT MONITORING ELECTRIC
FENCE SYSTEMS. IS GIVING HEADS
DIFFICULT COMPONENTS ON HOW
THEY WILL BE INSTALLED THE
SYSTEMS ARE NOT FOR RESIDENTIAL
OR AGRICULTURE USE THESE
SYSTEMS ARE DESIGNED TO
REINFORCE SECURITY MONITORING
BEHIND IT AND EXISTING
PERIMETER FENCE. OF A BUSINESS
SUCH AS A FREIGHT CARRIER LET'S
JUST LOGISTICS WAREHOUSE
DEALERSHIPS CAR REPAIR- SHOPS.
EQUIPMENT RENTAL SITES. THEY
ARE REMOVED FROM PUBLIC THE
PUBLIC AND ONLY TRIGGERED IF A
TRUST PASSING THE CURSE AND
ATTEMPT TO INTRUDE. SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION THE EXPERIENCE
ON PERMITTING AND APPROVAL
PROCESS RANGES WIDELY GIVEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT VIEWS.
óRDENES THE SYSTEM
UNFORTUNATELY IN SOME CASES AS
A RESULT OF DELAYS OR JUST-
DEFACTO DENIALS. THIS COOK THIS
CLARIFIED IN STATUTE IS NEEDED
TO AID WHERE THERE IS A LACK OF
CLEAR REGULATORY STRUCTURE AT A
LOCAL LEVEL THAT UNFORTUNATELY
CAUSES PERMITTING TO BE
INEFFECTIVE INCONSISTENT AND
THE LATE. I'M THRILLED TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
ELITIST CALIFORNIA CITIES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES TO TACKLE ALL THE
PERMITTING ISSUES. AB THREE
FIFTY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT
BUSINESSES HAVE THE PROPER
TOOLS. TO OBTAIN THIS AND
SECURE THE FACILITIES WITH
TECHNOLOGY IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND MAINTAIN PUBLIC SAFETY.
PROBABLY DETERRING TRUST
PASSING ASSOCIATE WITH IMPACT
OF THEFT BURGLARY VANDALISM AND
ENDANGERMENT TO EMPLOYEES. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AS LUIS SANTOS. AND KEITH- COME
OUT OF. SO ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU
I HAVE TO WITNESSES LISTED LUIZ.
OF THE TRUCKING SERVICE. AND
KEEP CONNECT GO WHO IS ON
STANDBY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
BOTH WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE.
MISTER SANCHEZ. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WE SANCHEZ
WITH MILLER SUSPENDED AN
ASSOCIATE ON BEHALF OF AB.
HEARING SO- LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR AND THE CAN- THE INTENT
THE BILL OF BUILD A PER PRE
ANAK LET. THAT CREATED CIVIL
CODE EIGHT THIRTY FIVE AND TO
PROVIDE GREATER ON THE
COMMITTEE USE IN INSTALLATION
OF MODERN HELLO. SECURITIES
STATEWIDE WHAT WE ULTIMATELY TO
CHIU IS TO BE ALLOW. OWNERS AND
BUSINESSES NEEDING PERIMETER
SECURITY TO PROTECT PROPERTY
BUSINESS AND- IN AN OFFICE AND
MANNER. LIKE TO BE OUT THERE
MAN WITH ME THAT ANY ANSWER
PARTNER QUESTIONS SHOULD BEAR
AS KEEP COMING. DIRECTOR
AFFAIRS FOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. SO IS THERE
ANYONE THE HEARING WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY
EIGHT. C. NONE ANYONE IS THE
REMOTE TEST STAY. SEEING
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB.
THREE FIFTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. YOUR CHAIRED
APPEARS THAT NO ONE IS SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
I'M SORRY WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE CANNOT TAKE A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT WELL WE WILL
SEE HAS NOW MOVED TO OPPOSITION
I HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FIFTY
EIGHT. SEE NON REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE ABOUT THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WHICH OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE B.
THREE FIFTY EIGHT. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR WE DO HAVE AT LEAST ONE
OF A PERSON WHO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU.
AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE FORTY
ONE FORTY OF ONE IS OPEN. IS
THIS ABOUT AB TEN SIXTY TWO NO
IT IS NOT. MY APOLOGIES NO
WORRIES HANG ON THE WORLD WE'LL
GET THERE PRETTY SOON. MISTER
CHAIR IT APPEARS THAT WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU
I'M GOING TO YOU MAY CLOSE THE
AND I'M GOING TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE BUT FIRST I'D
LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI.
GALLAGHER CHECK OUT HERE TO
DAVIES. GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA
KILEY MAIN SHOW FIFTH HERE. WE
DO A QUORUM THE STATUS OF TAKE
THAT MOTION. ALL RIGHT SO WE DO
HAVE A MOST AS A SECOND
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR. SEEING NONE MR FLORI
MAKE CLUB JUST RESPECT LESS
PRIVATE THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
CULTURAL PLEASE STONE HI STONE
AYE GALLAGHER CHAU. CHAU AYE
CHU DAVIES. DAVEY SECOND SALAS
CONSOLES I HOLD KALRA KILEY.
HALEY I MAIENSCHEIN REYES HI
RES I. THE BILL IS OUT
RESEARCHERS THANK YOU. TEKAMAH
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA. SECOND
OKAY WE HAVE MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE CAN AGENDA
CALDERON PLEASE STONE HI STONE
AYE SHOW CHOI I CHIU DAY. DAVEY
LIKE AND SALAS CONSOLES I HOLD.
KALRA ON CONSENT. RIGHT KALRA
KILEY. MOVED ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB ELEVEN OH ONE MISSOURI WITH.
AND THIS IS COMING UP I'LL TAKE
A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVEN FORTY SIX MOVE BY THIS
GONZALEZ SECOND ABOUT HIS
READINESS. THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHOW. CHOW I CHIU
DAVIES. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA FOR KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
REYES FIVE REYES AYE. THE
BILL'S OUT PERFECT ALL RIGHT I
REMEMBER THREE AB ELEVEN A ONE
BEDROOM THANK YOU AND THANK TO-
CHAIR STONE AND- GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS AB. ELEVEN OH ONE I DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WILL PROVIDE CLARITY ON
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S TECHNICAL CLEAN
UP MEASURE THAT DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE MEDITATION CONCERNS
FROM STAKEHOLDERS. I OFFICES AT
SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN WORKSHOPS
LANGUAGE THAT RESPOND TO
CONCERNS INITIALLY RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION WE SHARE THE
SAME GOAL OF SAFEGUARDING THE
FINANCES OF A TWO WAYS FROM
FRAUD AND ABUSE AND HOPE TO
REACH CONSENSUS ON. THE
THRESHOLD ISSUE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY ARE THOMAS WHERE
THE TOURNEY LITIGATED H. AWAY
FRAUD CASES AND STACEY DOLLY AN
EXPERT IN FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
FOR COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATIONS.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED THOMAS WHEREIN
STACEY DONNELLY BOTH WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE. THOMAS WHERE.
THANK YOU- AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF IRWIN SAID I AM I AM AN
ATTORNEY AT PRACTICE- REPRESENT
EACH ALWAYS FOR THE PAST THIRTY
TWO YEARS AND I HAVE DEVELOPED
EXPERTISE IN PROSECUTING
FIDELITY BOND CLAIMS TO HELP
THOSE SUBSTATIONS RECOUP
EMBEZZLED FUNDS- AND I'M
CURRENTLY LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR
FOR THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE. ACTION COMMITTEE
KNOWN AS CLASSIC. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE CLOCKS. ASSEMBLY
NUMBER WEDNESDAY TWENTY NINE
TWELVE WITH THE GOAL OF
PROTECTING ASSOCIATION FINANCES
BY MAKING SURE THAT BOARD
MEMBERS FOR VIEWING ASSOCIATION
FINANCE AS- MAKING SURE THAT
SIGNIFICANT TRANSFERS WILL BE
MADE THE BOARD APPROVAL. AND
THAT THE H. AWAY FOR PROPERTY
INSURED AGAINST THEFT BY
DIRECTORS OFFICERS MANAGEMENT
AGENCY AND MANAGEMENT COMPANY
EMPLOYEES. CLOCK BELIEVES IT AB
OR ELEVEN A ONE CLARIFIES THE
P. TWENTY NINE TWELVE AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE ACT
MITCHELL GOALS OF PROTECTING
SUBSTATION FINANCES. NOT CIVIL
CODE SECTION FIFTY EIGHT OH SIX
MANDATE SAID THE WHOLE
ASSOCIATION TO TANK THE
DELEGATE BOND COVERAGE TO MAKE
SURE THEY INSURE AGAINST THAT
BY THE DIRECTORS OFFICERS
MANAGEMENT AGENCY AND THE
MANAGEMENT COMPANY EMPLOYEES.
INSURANCE COVERAGE
TRADITIONALLY SMALLNESS WE WERE
FIRST TO THAT TYPE OF INSURANCE
AT THE DELION QUITE BUT ONLY
BONDS ARE NOW OFFERED TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INSURANCE
INSTRUMENTS SUCH AS CRIME
INSURANCE EMPLOYEE DISHONESTY
POLICIES PROVIDE THE SAME TYPE
OF COVERAGE. S. B. ELEVEN OH
ONE CLARIFIES THAT SUCH
POLICIES WILL SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE ACT SO LONG
AS THEY MEET THE COVERAGE
LIMITS AND SCOPE OF COVERAGE
MANDATES PROVIDE EVIDENCE CIVIL
CODE SECTION FIFTY EIGHT OH
SIX. AND I'M MAINLY CONCERNED
GET STAFFED BUT THE DIRECTORS
OFFICERS MANAGEMENT AGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMPANY POISED AND
PROVIDE FOR A COMPUTER FUND
FUNDS TRANSFERRED INSURANCE IN
THE- ABOUT COVERAGE LIMITS
MEANT IT DIDN'T ACT. IN
ADDITION A CIVIL CODE SECTION
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED WAS MODIFIED
BY AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE TO
MANDATE THAT THE BOARD REVIEW
THEIR FINANCES ON A MONTHLY
BASIS. THE ACT ALSO MANDATES
THAT ALL TRANSFERS OF GREATER
THAN TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS OR 5%
OF THE HOAS TOTAL COMBINED
RESERVE AN OPERATING ACCOUNTS
WHICHEVER IS LOWER YOU MUST BE
APPROVED IN WRITING BY. THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THIS SO 5%
CREEK WITH FOR THE ACT DOES NOT.
WHEN ARE THIS COPE CAL. AB
HELLO A ONE OF THIS COULD BACK
A- QUESTION. FOR TRANSFER THAT
RECALL PRIOR WRITTEN- TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FOR A WAYS
WITH FIFTY OR MORE UNITS. AND A
LOWER COURT OF COURSE SOCIUS OF
THOUSAND. OR MORE WHICH WITH
FIFTY UNITS ARE. SEVERAL FIFTY
THREE EIGHTY CURRENT MANDATE
THAT HOME H. MANAGERS THE TOP
H. FUNDS TO PAY. I CAN'T PARDEE
WITH ONE TO BANKS AND CREDIT
CAN. HOWEVER THIS MAN AT THE
FUNDS MY BE MEAN AT FTA AND
ACCOUNTS. CREDIT UNIONS ARE NOT
AFTER ENSURE BUT RATHER
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED BY
NATIONAL CREDIT UNION-
INSURANCE SPOT SB ELEVEN A ONE
CLARIFIES THAT MANAGERS MAY
CONTINUE TO DEPOSIT ASSOCIATION
FUNDS ENTER CREDIT UNION
ACCOUNT PROVIDED THAT IT IS.
AFFECTED BY THE NATIONAL CREDIT.
UNION INSURANCE GONE. LIKELY
THAT S. B. A ONE IS A NO CON
BILL CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS
OF AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE.
PROTECTING ASSOCIATION FINANCES
ACCORDINGLY WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
HI. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. STACEY DONNELLY.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE STACEY
DONNELLY. RICHARD JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE HELP CHECK ON THAT. AND
PARDON ME. JUST A MOMENT.
DONNELLY YOUR PHONE LINE HAS
NOW BEEN JOINED TO THE CALL THE
CHAIRS CALLED UPON YOU TO SPEAK.
OKAY THANK YOU HOW MUCH QUICKER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS STACY
DONNELLY AND I- ANY. MEMBER OF
THE LSC COMMITTEE FOR THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE I AM ALSO THEIR CFO
AS CONDOMINIUM FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT AND WE PROVIDE
BOOKKEEPING SERVICES FOR COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS AND HAVE
DONE SO FOR OVER FORTY SIX
YEARS. I PERSONALLY BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS. AND I AM
HERE. TODAY TO DISCUSS- AB
ELEVEN OH ONE TO PROVIDE SOME
CLEAN UP CHIU AB TWENTY NINE
TWELVE WHICH WAS PASSED INTO
LAW. JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. SO NOW THAT WE'VE HAD
A COUPLE OF YEARS TO EXPERIENCE
AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE IN ACTUAL
PRACTICE WHICH IS BEING DONE
AREAS THAT NEED FURTHER
CLARIFICATION. I'M CURRENTLY
THERE IS A CALCULATION REQUIRED
WITH RESPECT SHE TRANSFERS ARE
ALLOWED BY MANAGING AGENTS. AND
THAT CALCULATION CAN CHANGE ON
A DAILY BASIS AS IT RELATES TO
BALANCE OF THE BANK ACCOUNTS
CURRENTLY ABOUT HOW THE LAW IS
STRUCTURED. SO WHAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR IS A MORE DEFINITIVE
THRESHOLD TO MAKE IT. A LITTLE
BIT EASIER FOR MANAGING AGENTS
TO DETERMINE. WHEN THE
TRANSFERS ARE ALLOWED AND WHEN
THEY NEED TO SEEK APPROVAL.
ALSO AND FOR THE PROTECTION ON
HOW HOAS INVESTED THEIR MONEY
REQUIRING PROTECTION AS
PRINCIPAL IN THE NEW WORKING
AFTER A LOT. AND LASTLY I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THERE'S
FURTHER PROTECTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO COMPUTER FRAUD AND
FUNDS TRANSFER PRIVATE. MY
COMPANY ACTUALLY PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED A LOSS IN THIS
ARENA AND IT'S THE FASTEST
GROWING LOS STREETER FOR OUR
INDUSTRY. DOES BEST- WORDING IN
THAT PROPOSAL. HAS INCREASED
PROTECTIONS FOR COMPUTER FRAUD
AND FUNDS TRANSFER INSURANCE.
FOR YOUR TIME. AND WE'RE JUST
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. VISIT ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A
BI ELEVEN A ONE. SEEING NONE
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM
I SEE. NON OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI ELEVEN A ONE. AT THIS
TIME WE'RE TAKING NAMES
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PICTURE WE HAVE- SEVERAL PEOPLE
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED- THAT THEY
WISH TO SIGNAL THEIR SUPPORT
JUST A MOMENT PLACE THANK YOU.
I'LL NOW GO TO LINE. THIRTY
ONE. JENNIFER WHAT I BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGER IN THE COURT.
LINE THE. FORTY FIVE. ARE THE
TEARS ON WE HAVE THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE WITH
SUPPORT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO MAKE
I THANK YOU OPERATOR WE WILL.
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED
MARJORIE MARIE AND TOM SIR.
MARJORIE MARIE VOTER ON THE
TELEPHONE MARJORIE MARIE ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI MARJORIE MURRAY
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW WE
ARE A NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES
FOR THE CONSUMER AND CIVIL
RIGHTS OF HOMEOWNERS. I AM
ACTUALLY SEEDING MY TIME TO
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
COMMISSIONER TOM SERVER A
MEMBER OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. HE WILL PRAISE HER
PRESENT THE TESTIMONY OF A
SENIOR HOMEOWNERS IMPACTED BY
A. B. ELEVEN OH ONE WHO WAS
UNABLE TO BE HERE IN PERSON
TODAY. THE TESTIMONY FROM THE
HOMEOWNER LAYS OUT HOW THE
BOARD OF HIS SENIOR COMMUNITY
AT THE URGING OF THE PROPERTY
MANAGER AND ASSOCIATION LAW
FIRM IS BREAKING EXISTING LAW
ON ASSOCIATION RESERVISTS. AND
PUTTING THEIR ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AT RISK I SEE
MY TIME TO TOM SIR I'M SORRY
THERE'S NO SEATING OF TIME
EVERYONE HAS AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME ALLOWING ABOUT THREE
MINUTES SO. MISTER SIR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
AM READING THE TESTIMONY OF
BILL RICHARDSON. I AM THE
FORMER AUDITOR THE PANEL TO
BILLS WILL COUNTY AND A FORMER
MAYOR WHO LIVES IN A SENIOR
COMMUNITIES WHERE I WAS BOARD
PRESIDENT FOR SIX YEARS. MY
NEIGHBORS AND I'VE BEEN TRYING
FOR MONTHS TO GET COPIES OF THE
ABILITIES AND FINANCES BECAUSE
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DECISIONS THAT THE BOARD HAVE
BEEN MAKING ABOUT THE ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. IN A
RESERVE ACCOUNT. I HAVE READ
BUILDING DETERMINED GET
PRESENTED WITH CANADIAN I'VE
STUDIED THE LOG ON RESERVE
ACCOUNT. OUR ONE POINT TWO
MILLION IN RESERVES ONE
DEPOSITED IN A FEDERALLY
INSURED BANK AT THE LAW
REQUIRES HOWEVER EIGHTY ELEVEN
OH ONE CONTAINS NO IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY
ACTUALLY HE THERE IN FACT OUR
MANAGEMENT COMPANY BACKED BY
THE ASSOCIATION THE LAWYERS.
RECENTLY CONVINCED OUR BOARD TO
MOVE THE READER OUT OF OUR
FEDERALLY INSURED BANK ACCOUNT.
AND GIVE THEM TO BROKER DEALERS.
WHOSE ACCOUNTS ARE NOT INSURE.
SO FAR THE BORDERS MOVES TO
HUNDRED DOLLAR. OUT OF OUR AT
BE INSURED BANK AND ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
SCHEDULED TO BE HANDLED BURKE.
IN MORGAN STANLEY AND WELLS
FARGO ADVISORS. DESPITE
REPEATED REQUESTS WE'VE BEEN
UNABLE TO COME. YET COMPLETE
FINANCE OF THE DETAILS AND WHAT
THE TWO COMPANIES ARE DOING
WITH OUR MONEY ARE THEY COULD
THEY GET INTO TOP ARE THEY
PROTECTING THE PRINCIPLE HOW
MUCH ARE THEY CHARGING US IN
MANAGING. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
THAT OUR VISITORS ARE NO LONGER
FEDERALLY INSURED. EIGHTY
ELEVEN OH ONE THAT THE MONEY.
WON'T BE DEPOSITED INTO RISKY
INVESTMENTS LIKE THE STOCK
MARKET. THE BILL HAS NO TEETH
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS WHAT
THEY'RE AFTER THE CHANCE WE CAN
DISCUSS WITH INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE THE BOARD IS STILL
WHILE THE WE FINALLY DECIDED WE
HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO ACT ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. TO HELP
WITH SEND OFF WHAT APPEARS TO
BE ELDER FINANCIAL ABUSE. THE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN TURN ASKED THE TEN
MINUTES OBISPO POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO INVESTIGATE.
ACCORDING TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE BOARD IN
SPENDING. FINANCIAL BUT THE
ASSOCIATION LAW FIRM IS
REVIEWING THEM FIRST. IF WE DO
HAVE EATEN UP OUR ENTIRE LEGAL
BUDGET FOR THE YEAR. OUR BOARD
CAN'T JUST PROVE TO US THAT
WITHOUT IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
RESERVE ACCOUNT. THE LAW IS
USELESS AB ELEVEN OH ONE THAT
THE BOARD CAN'T BE HAUNTED.
HELLO EVERYBODY IT'S A RISKY
INVESTMENT. BUT WHO'S GOING TO
STOP THEM FROM TRANSFERRING ARE
STUCK. WE ARE SENIOR EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE TO NINE EIGHT. IF
THE MONEY IS LOCKED WE CAN'T GO
BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE. TO
REPLACE IT. AND SO WE URGE A NO
VOTE ON A BILL OF THE ONE BY
THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION AB
ELEVEN A ONE. C. NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD IKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ELEVEN A.
ONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE- PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK TO.
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT SEEING NONE IS
THERE WHEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
CERTAINLY THE AB- TWENTY NINE
TWELVE A ON A CURRENTLY AB
ELEVEN OH ONE ARE ADDRESSING
EXACTLY THE CONCERNS THAT THE
OPPONENTS HAVE RAISED AND- I DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF YOUR-
STAFF MISTER CHAIR I WOULD.
KINDLY DIRECT ATTENTION TO
PAGES FIVE AND SIX THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH
DESCRIBES HOW MANY CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE OPPOSITION.
REGARD PROVISIONS THAT ARE IN
EXISTING LAWS. OR READY AND
DRESSED BY THIS BILL AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASCHAL WILL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER CHAU. CHAO
I CHOOSE. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN REYES
FIVE REYES I'VE. THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
TEXAS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ONE
SIXTY TWO MR MATHIS. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WITH THE MOTION IN THE
SECOND I WILL KEEP MY REMARKS
BRIEF. AB TEN SIXTY TWO SIMPLY
ENSURES THAT. AS OUR ELDERLY
PASSED AWAY THEIR KEEPSAKES ARE
ABLE TO MOVE ON- WITH THE
FAMILIES AND THOSE WHO MAY WANT
THEM AND WITH THAT I'D ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS THANK YOU AND THERE
ARE AMENDMENTS INDICATED IN THE
YES I WAS VERY SORRY I HAD THE
MOTION THE SECOND- YES I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS I DO HONESTLY WANT
TO THANK THE- COMMITTEE STAFF-
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL- I
BELIEVE ALL THE AMENDMENTS AND
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEES DONE HAS- AN
EMOTIONAL OF FIDE THE
OPPOSITION'S. COMPLAINTS TO THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU LIKE
THANK YOU I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES INDICATED TERRY
WILLIAMS. AND SERENA COULD
REVILING. TERRY WILLIAMS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE BOTH ON THE
TELEPHONE I AM. GLAD I AM.
HELLO GOOD MORNING TO THE CHAIR
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TERRY
WILLIAMS CONCERNED CITIZEN
VICTIM ADVOCATE AND
JOURNALISTIC FLOORS. I AM
CALLING TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI TURN SIXTY TWO
SEEKING A LONG AWAITED
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PROTECTION OF OTHERWISE
VULNERABLE KEEPSAKES AND TRUST
ASSETS HAVING LONG ESCAPED
JUDICIAL OVERSIGHT. MOLESTING
GRATEFUL TO SEE THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION I IMPLORE ALL
WITHIN THE REACH OF THE SOUND
OF MY VOICE TO IMAGINE HOW YOU
MAY FEEL. SHOULD A STRANGER
TAKE OVER YOUR PERCENT AN
AFFAIR WITH THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS CONVENE YOUR MOST
CHERISHED KEEPSAKES VALUE LIST
AND YOUR HARD FOUGHT FOR TRUST
ASSETS A NEW FOUND SECRET
SOURCE OF TELLING INCOME.
EXISTING OFF THE BOOKS. AND NOT
SUBJECT TO ACCOUNTING. I'VE
SEEN SOME OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
INSTANCE AND OF IT WOULD BE
SURE OF CONSERVAPEDIA AND THEIR
FAMILIES. ONE COULD NEVER
IMAGINE GENERATIONS OF FAMILY
HISTORY AND PRICELESS SOURCES
OF PRIDE GONE IN THE BLINK OF
AN ONLINE. LIKE WIDE I HAVE
SEEN CONSERVATORS AND GUARDIANS
SEEK APPOINTMENT AS SUCCESSOR
TRUSTEE FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
CLOAKING THEMSELVES TO AVOID
DETECTION I WAS TRUST ASPECT IT
APPEARS. PROFESSIONAL I DO
SHERRY. GIVEN COMPLETE AND SOLE
DISCRETION TO DEEM PERSONAL
EFFECTS ALULA AND SQUANDER
TRUST ASSETS IS AN EMOTIONAL
AND FINANCIAL ASSAULT HAVING
DEEP IMPACT AND LONGSTANDING
CONSEQUENCES. I WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO IMAGINE DECADES
LONG CANARIA OR COMPLETE LOSS
OF EVIDENCE OF THE ONES YOU
DEVELOPMENT CAREER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND PRODUCTIVE
WELL REPRODUCTIVE RECORDS WITH
SALTS FROM INCENTIVES CAL YOU
JUDGMENT. IT SUCH EVIDENCE TO
BE THROWN AWAY LIKE TRASH
LITERALLY. ARE WE NO LONGER TO
TELL FAMILY STORIES AIDED BY
DOCUMENTS PHOTOS OUR PARENTS
HIGH SCHOOL YEARBOOKS
ILLUSTRATING INTELLECT STANDING
AND FUTURE PROBLEMS NO LONGER
ABLE TO SHOW OUR RESEMBLANCE TO
GRANDPARENTS. OUR LOVED ONES
ASHES KEEPSAKES AWARDS AND
COMMENDATIONS ARE HARDLY VALUE
LIST I'M CERTAIN THAT MANY OF
US HAVING A CHANCE TO PRESERVE
OUR FAMILY HISTORY VIA NOTICED
WHAT APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO
RESCUE ITEMS EVIDENCING HOW ARE
FAMILIES CAME TO BE. SIMILARLY
BEING AFFORDED THE ABILITY TO
MONITOR DEPLETION OF TRUST
ASSETS NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF OUR LOVED ONES IT'S EQUALLY
AS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THIS WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING CHURCHTOWN
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS AN UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF YOUTH
IN YOUR BODY I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FIFTY TWO.
I'M SURE MANY OF US HERE HAVE
LOST A LOVED ONE ARE NO CLOSE
FRIENDS WHO LOST LOVED ONES
DURING THE CAN GET. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAPPENS IMAGINE
LIVING YOUR ELDERLY PARENT OR
GRANDPARENT WHO HAD BEEN
CONSIDERED AN ISOLATED FROM YOU
FOR A REALLY LONG TIME. AND YOU
HAVE NO OPPORTUNITY TO RETRIEVE
YOUR PRECIOUS FAMILY PHOTO
ALBUM VINTAGE ITEM OR MOMENTO
FROM THAT. AFTER THEIR DEATH.
THESE ITEMS WHICH I JUST
MENTIONED ARE REFERRED TO ADD
VALUE WITH PROPERTY JEFF
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HOLD
FINANCIAL POWER. POINTING
TOWARDS DECIDED. MATERIALISTIC
MINDSET. I THINK WE NEED TO
ASSEMBLY VALUE I. NO THEY'RE
NOT THESE ITEMS CALLED
SIGNIFICANT EMOTIONAL VALUE AND
SERVICE LIFE LONG MEMORIES FOR
THE FAMILY MEMBERS. OF THE
DISEASE COMPARED. IF THE
VALUABLE MEMORIES. TO THE
ATTACHED TO THE CALLED WITH
ITEMS. THAT OFTEN BRINGS THE
NUMBER THAT. HAVE NOT MISTER
MIGHT. ON THE OTHER HAND SOME
CONSERVATIVES FIVE IN I JUST BE
ACQUIRING FINANCIAL GAIN. WHEN
I CAN EVER BE SIX TRACKING OF A
TO THE FUTURE. BOTH TRIED ACTED
MAKING PROVISION OF THE CORE.
AND THEY WILL CALL AT SOME
PROFESSIONAL CONSERVATIVE
COMMIT I'M JUST ACT LIKE
BALLING THERE CAN THERE BE
HOMES. AND TAKING CONTROL OVER
SUBSTANTIAL INHERITANCES THAT
WERE INTENDED FOR THE
CONSERVATIVE. OFTENTIMES THE
VICTIMS THERE BE THAT ARE
INVOLVEDOF A POSITION WHERE
THEY CAN'T SPEAK UP AND FIGHT
FOR THEMSELVES. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO HAVE POOR
OVERSIGHT. ON THEIR SIDE.
THEREFORE I. REQUEST FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY TEN FIFTY TWO SO
THAT ONE CAN NEVER GIVE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND INTERESTED PERSONS
OF THE VERY. FIFTEEN DAY
SURGERY PERSONAL PROPERTY PRIOR
TO THE ITEMS BEING ABANDONED OR
DISCARDED BY THE COMPARATOR.
AND YOU SAID THAT COURT YOU
COULD BEGIN AS REQUIRED WHEN
ACCUSED EVERY BECOME SUCCESSOR
TRUSTEE TO COMPARE DESTRESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU AND. WOULD YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR A RECORD PLEASE.
SURE OF RIGHT FROM YOU THINK
YOU'RE- GREAT THANK YOU. IT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- LIKE TO SPEAK CONSERVE OF
A TEN TWO. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TEST SITE. SEEING NONE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN
SIXTY TWO. FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THEY HAVE
SEVERAL WHO'S WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK ONE MOMENT.
WELL NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY SECS.
GOOD MORNING TEARS DOWN VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM JULIE
SEBASTIAN PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
JUST CULTURALLY SUPER SERVICE
INCORPORATED I'VE BEEN
PROVIDING IN HOME CARE GIVING
SERVICES FOR SEVEN CALIFORNIA'S
SENIORS FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
SIX YEARS I OFFER MY FULL
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY NINE. THIS IS SALIM
BALLOT OFF WITH THE
CONSERVATORSHIP REFORM PROJECT
AND THESE ITEMS THAT ARE DEEMED
OF VALUE LIST BY CONSERVATIVES
ARE HAVE WE'RE NOT ABLE TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY WHICH IS
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN SIXTY TWO.
THE WIND OUT OF CONSERVATORSHIP
REFORM PROJECT AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BLINDS. FIFTY THREE.
OKAY OTHER THAN HIGHER STATE
WAS TAKEN BY HER CONSERVATOR IN
SUPPORT. BUYING A FIFTY SIX
RICHARD CALLAHAN CO FOUNDER OF
CEDAR AND SPONSOR THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE
IS NO WENT OUT TO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU OPERATOR I'M NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN SIXTY TWO.
SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
WITNESS VIDEO ROW. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
TEN SIXTY TWO. ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SIGNAL THEIR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE AT LEAST
ONE ONE PERSON WHO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK ONE MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE.
TWENTY FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS JERRY DOESN'T END
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ARE
CONCERNED WITH MEASURE S.
EXPRESSED IN THE- COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND SHARED WITH TAX-
IS THAT THE NOTICE PROVISIONS
AS CURRENTLY WORDED BUT
ACCOMPLISHED ANY PROPERTY THAT
TECHNICALLY HAS NO MONETARY
VALUE AND WOULD TRIGGER A
NOTICE APARTMENT IN ALL CASES.
YOU'LL MISS AND TURN A COULD
TRIGGER PETITIONS TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES REGRDING THE RIGHT TO
VALUE LIST PARK- PROPERTY UP
AND LIKELY BETWEEN FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT WILL BURDEN THE
PARTS AND FOR THAT REASON WE
CONTINUE WITH OUR POSITION. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
BEIN. FORTY NINE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YES. SO WE'VE GONE UP
WITH THE CONSERVATORSHIP REFORM
PROJECT AND THE ONE PROBLEM
WITH THIS BILL IS THAT LIKE.
ALMOST THE ENTIRE SECTIONS OF
THE PROBATE CODE THAT RELATE TO
CONSERVATORSHIP IS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY KEY. THERE'S NO-
PENALTY FOR FAILING TO GIVE
NOTICE. ABOUT THESE-
POSSESSIONS WHICH ARE SOMETIMES
THE ONLY WAY THAT A PERSON WITH
DEMENTIA CAN RECOGNIZE THE
ROOM- IS BY HAVING A PICTURE OF
THEMSELVES AN OLD ONE. SO I
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
AMEND THIS BILL. SO THAT THERE
ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR FAILING TO
GIVE NOTICE JUST LIKE WE HAVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR FAILING TO PAY
TAXES ARE UNDER REPORTING TAXES
OR DRIVING BEYOND THE SPEED
LIMIT- UNFORTUNATELY WE SEE ALL
TOO OFTEN CONSERVATORS IGNORING.
B. STATUTES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE JEFF FAST AND THEN
THE COURT BRUSHING IT UNDER THE
RUG SO- I WOULD SUGGEST A
PENALTY ENFORCEABLE IN SMALL
CLAIMS COURT OR A CIVIL COURT
NOT NECESSARILY THE PROBATE
COURT TO ENSURE THAT DENTURE.
POLICY IS IN FACT HONORED AND
NOT SIMPLY IGNORED. THANK YOU.
SURE THERE IS NO ONE UP TO TAKE
NOTE THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THEN QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SINGH NATT MISTER
MATHIS YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN STONE- MEMBERS AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS- I DO AGREE WITH ONE POINT
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT I DO
WISH THIS HAD A LITTLE MORE
TEETH TO IT- SO PEOPLE WOULD
STOP PLAYING GAMES WITH OUR
SENIORS. ON WITHOUT ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. BY GALLAGHER AYE
CHOW. CHOW I CHOOSE DAVIES.
DAVIES I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN RIESS
REASSIGNED. THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU THE TEXAS TO OUR ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWO FIFTY FIVE
CONSUMER TUCCI. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
AB TWO FIVE FIVE THE COVER
NINETEEN SMALL BUSINESS
EVICTION RELIEF FACT. AS WE ALL
KNOW THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING ON SMALL BUSINESSES
AND ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS. OVER
40% OF SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
ALREADY SHUT DOWN. OR AT RISK
OF SHUTTING DOWN. WITH MANY OF
THOSE CONCENTRATED IN EMIGRANT
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WHILE
OUR ECONOMY IS STARTING TO RE
OPEN SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
SAYING THE SAME THINGS THAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM A
RESIDENTIAL TENANTS THAT
THEY'RE BEING SADDLED WITH THE
DEBT. OF UNPAID RENT. LAST FALL
I WENT ON SEVERAL TOURS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES IN MY
DISTRICT. AND I WAS REALLY
STRUCK BY HOW I WAS HEARING. HI
I LIKE LIKE THE FACT THAT MR
CHIU IS WALKING IN BECAUSE I
WANTED REFERENCE A YOU KNOW I
WAS HEARING THE SAME THINGS
THAT I WAS HEARING. IN TERMS OF
OUR RESIDENTIAL TENANTS. READ
RELIEF AN EVICTION RELIEVE
DEBATE WITHOUT THE BILL THAT.
WE PASSED LAST YEAR AB THREE
ZERO EIGHT EIGHT. THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THE TENANTS THE
COMMERCIAL TENANTS. THEY WERE
SAYING THE SAME THINGS THAT WE
ARE HEARING FROM A RESIDENTIAL
TENANTS. TO GIVE US SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO PAY
OUR RENT YOU KNOW I WAS TALKING
TO RESTAURANT OWNERS AND- THE
THEY THEY COULDN'T OPERATE
THERE IS SAYING THAT YOU KNOW
WE CAN PAY OUR EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE WE GOT THE PPP. LOANS
BUT- WE CAN'T PAY OUR RENT AND
WE TRY TO NEGOTIATE WITH THEIR
LANDLORDS AND WHILETHE GOOD
THE GOOD SO CALLED GOOD
LANDLORDS. THEY WOULD GIVE THEM
BREAKS THEY WOULD WORK WITH
THEM. BUT TOO MANY OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE HEARD FROM
THEY WERE SAYING THAT- THEY
WERE NOT- GETTING ANY BREAK
FROM THEIR LANDLORDS. AND SO
THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DO IS TRY TO GIVE
THEM A BREAK IS TRYING TO GIVE
US SOME FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
SMALL BUSINESS COMMERCIAL
TENANTS CAN WORK WITH THEIR
LANDLORDS. IF DATE SUBMIT A
CERTIFICATE OF HARDSHIP SO THAT
THEY'VE- SUFFERED SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN REVENUES DURING
THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH REGULATIONS. THAT
AND THE LANDLORD HAS TO ENGAGE
IN A GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATION- IN
ORDER TO TRY TO WORK WITH THEM
TO GIVE THEM A PAYMENT SCHEDULE.
THIS BILL. SEEKS TO TAKE A
BALANCED APPROACH AGAIN YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE LESSONS I
LEARNED FROM OUR RESIDENTIAL
TENANT DEBATE THAT- WHILE WE
WANT TO HELP OUR- OUR SMALL
BUSINESS TENANTS. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LANDLORDS
ALSO RELY ON THE REVENUES FROM
THE RENT- AND SO THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
IN THE CASE WHERE. LANDLORDS
CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY WOULD
SUFFER A SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP
IF THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO-
COLLECT- THE RENT TO AS AS
THEIR TENANTS THEIR COMMERCIAL
SMALL BUSINESS CENTER ASKING
FOR. THAT THEY WOULD BE DEEMED
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
SO AGAIN I THINK THIS IS TAKE
TRYING TO TAKE A- YOU KNOW A
BALANCED- REASONABLE APPROACH
TO WORK WITH OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES WORK WITH THERE ARE.
COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS THAT'S IT
FOR A TRY TO PROVIDE THEM SOME
EVICTION RELIEF. I HEAR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS DIANE
MATSUDA A STAFF ATTORNEY- WITH
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGAL OUTREACH. THANK YOU M. S.
REDUCE HEAT THERE ARE SOME
AMENDMENTS ARE YOU TAKING THOSE
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS YES SIR AND I
WANT TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF I KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH MY
STAFF- WE- AS YOU KNOW WE
SIGNIFICANTLY PARED DOWN OUR
BILL IN ORDER TO TRY TO.
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE COMMERCIAL BUSINESS
PROPERTY OWNERS- AND- WE-
APPRECIATE AND ACCEPT ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS BEING PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU I
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE SUPPORT
WITNESSES OR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. LISTED BUT IS YOUR
WITNESS ON THE LINE. OPERATOR
DO YOU HAVE ANYONE ONLINE WHO
HAD INDICATED THAT THERE A
WITNESS. IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
FIFTY FIVE. I'M A TEACHER WE'RE
GOING TO INVESTIGATE THAT RIGHT
NOW WE MAY HAVE SOMEBODY. THANK
YOU. END UP PARDON ME UP ONE
FIFTY EIGHT IF YOU ARE IN FACT
A WITNESS FOR THIS CALL I'M
GOING TO OPEN YOUR LINE I WOULD
NEED TO IDENTIFY IF YOU ARE A
WITNESS. LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ARE YOU A WITNESS FOR THE CITY
FOR THIS CALL. I WAS TRYING TO
PROVIDE- OUR SUPPORT THIS IS
PERSONAL IT OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA THE
GREAT EIGHTY TWO FIVE FIVE
THANK YOU. THIS WHERE DID YOU
WHO IS YOUR FOR ALL RIGHTY OF
THOUGHT WE HAD- DIçN MATSU
TO- WITH THE- ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGAL OUT OF REACH
OKAY OPERATORS IS THERE A DIANE
MATSUDA. THE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR WERE WE'RE GONNA LOOK
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU.
NOT IT
DOES NOT APPEAR THAT WE HAVE
THIS PERSON ON THE LINE AS A
WITNESS FOR THE CALL SIR. OKAY
WILL BUT LET'S JUST OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWO FIFTY FIVE. AB AT TWELVE
FORTY THREE NO IT AB TWO FIFTY
FIVE. THIS IS FOR THE ELDER
ABUSE. NO THIS IS THE ONE TWO
FOUR THREE HELLO THIS IS AB.
TWO FIFTY FIVE. OKAY I'M
WAITING FOR THAT ONE TWO FOUR
THREE OPERATOR COULD YOU MOVE
ON PLEASE. ONE MOMENT MISTER
SURE. AND PARDON ME IF YOU ARE
A WITNESS INVITED TO SPEAK ON
THIS CALL PLEASE USE YOUR VIEW
BUT WE'RE NOT SPEAKING- AND
WHEN YOUR BILL IS CALLED THAT A
NEW TRIP OF MINE THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND AGAIN FOR TO SPEAK IS TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR IT
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE NOW WON.
OKAY THANK YOU WAS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIFTY FIVE. SEEING NONE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. C. NONE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION AGAIN I HAVE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES INDICATED
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWO FIFTY
FIVE. SEEING NONE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING NONE HOW ABOUT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SAY. RIGHT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWO FIFTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO WE HAVE
SEVERAL LINES THAT HAVE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. ONE OF THOSE PHONE LINES
MAY HAVE BEEN A PHONE LINE THAT
WAS ATTEMPTED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT- BUT THEY WEREN'T THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO PROCESS
THEMSELVES AND PROPERLY. OKAY
THAT'S JUST A MOMENT. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX.
LINE TWENTY SIX ALIGN IS OPEN.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS MATTHEW
HARPER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE TODAY WORKING WITH
THE BUILDING OWNERS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE INTERNATIONAL
COUNCIL OF SHOPPING CENTERS AND
NAY OFF OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL NOW- BUT
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THANK YOUR STAFF VERY VERY
MUCH FOR- THE LOOK THEY
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED- WE ARE WORKING TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION- AT WITH
THE OFFER WE HAVE A NEW
AMENDMENT THAT WILL BE ASKING
FOR AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
PROCESS BUT WE LOOK. FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OFTEN HAVE
STAFF- COMMERCIAL TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS BOTH THE STRAGGLERS
TROUBLE TO COLLECT SHUTDOWNS-
OUR MEMBERS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO WORK
WITH THEIR TENANTS BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT OPEN SPACES ONCE WE
COME OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC IN
THAT- PROPERTIES OPEN BACK UP-
WITHIN OUR MEMBERSHIP WE HAVE
YET TO TRACK DOWN ANY
COMMERCIAL LANDLORD WHO'S NOT
WORKING WITH THEIR TENANTS
BECAUSE. THEY WANT TO KEEP
THOSE TENANTS AND STATE. YEAH
KNOW THAT THEIR PUBLIC OUT THE-
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW. THAT OUR INDUSTRY IS
WORKING WITH TENANTS BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T BENEFIT ANYONE TO HAVE
OPEN COMMERCIAL SPACES. THE ONE
BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
IDEA AND AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT. IS ON THE RESIDENTIAL
SIDE YOU ALL PROVIDED FUNDING
FOR A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. THE
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM WORKED ON
THE COMMERCIAL SIDE THERE IS NO
FUNDING CONNECTED TO THIS BILL.
SO THAT HAVE BEEN PART OF OUR
STRUGGLE OF WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
COULD COME. TO LANGUAGE THAT WE
CAN PULL OUR OPPOSITION ON. SO
WITH THAT AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR YOUR STAFF AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH-
EVERYONE MOVING FORWARD AND
HOPE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PULL OPPOSITION SEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBER KATHY VAN
OSTERN REPRESENTING ANY
BROTHERS REAL ESTATE GROUP-
GOVERNMENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
WHICH WE ARE PROTECTING
AMENDMENTS WE REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR STEVE CURRY BUT
COULDN'T STRATEGIES ON BEHALF
OF WESTFIELD AND WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS FROM- CPA AND THE
KNOWLEDGE THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THE STAFF-
PREHEAT THE BACK AND FORTH IT
IS CERTAINLY GETTING. BETTER
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE BUT THERE
ARE SOME OF THE MAIN ISSUES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
BUT AGAIN WATER KNOWLEDGE TO-
WORK BY DR WORKING WITH OUR
WITH OUR CLIENTS AND THE
INDUSTRY. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTEEN
YES SIR GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CREAM GREASY
ON THE APP THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS NOT A
NATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES ON AB. TWO
FIFTY FIVE IT'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENT WAS DAVIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
OBVIOUSLY- LANDLORDS AS WELL
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN HIT
BUT THIS AND THERE IS NO
FINANCIAL- BACK UP HERE. MY
ONLY QUESTION HERE IS YOU KNOW
THE LANDLORD MUST ENGAGE IN
GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATIONS. WHAT
IS GOOD FATE THAT'S MY CONCERN
IS THAT IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S OPEN
VERY MUCH SO PERHAPS THE-
LANDLORD THINGS THAT WAS GOOD
FAITH WHAT HE DID BUT THE
TENANT DOESN'T FEEL THAT WAY.
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU KNOW IT'S
KIND OF LIKE IF THERE WAS A GUY
YOU DID THIS THIS AND THIS AND
THIS. AND THAT WAY THEY COULD
DO CHECK WITH KNOWING THAT OR
IF I DID ALL THAT. IT THAT'S
THAT'S GOOD. YES- SO. TO
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. SUGGESTS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO- GIVE MORE
DETAIL TO WHAT THAT MEANS- TO
HAVE A GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATION
BUT- I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT. YOU KNOW I THINK WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE MAIN CONCERN OF.
OF THE BUSINESS PROPERTY OWNERS
WHEN WE- SPECIFICALLY INSERTED
THE PROVISION. INDICATED THAT
THEY WOULD- A LANDLORD WOULD BE
DEEMED TO BE IN COMPLIANCE. IF
THEY COULD DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY WOULD BE IN FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP- WITH THE- THE AND THE
TERMS OF THE- THAT THE- THE
RENT- NEGOTIATIONS THEY'RE
THEY'RE TAKING PLACE. SO IF
THAT WOULD. YOU KNOW BASICALLY
GIVE LIKE AN AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE TO AN AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE DEFENSE IF THE LANDLORD
CAN SHOW THAT. THEY CAN'T PAY
THEIRMORTGAGE THEY CAN'T PAY
THEIR- PROPERTY TAXES IT SAID
OR ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
HEARD. FROM THE RESIDENTIAL
TENANCY BAIT- THEN THEY WOULD
BE DEEMED IN COMPLIANCE BUT IT.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK OUT
PERFECTLY. I THINK THAT'S ALL I
WANT TO SEE THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY GUIDELINES THERE SO
THAT IT'S AND- YOU KNOW.
THERE'S NO QUESTION WHATSOEVER
SO THAT BOTH OF THEM ARE
PROTECTED. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU RESEARCH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHARGED ONE UP THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR TACKLING THIS
AND IMPORTANT. I THINK EVERYONE
OF US- HAVE HEARD FROM
COUNTLESS SMALL BUSINESS
TENANTS REALLY STRUGGLING
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD AND- I
FOR ONE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION THIS PAST YEAR ROUND
RESIDENTIAL TENANTS BUT THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AN AREA- THAT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO TACKLE I KNOW
IT'S NOT EASY- JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR- WORKING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS I
KNOW HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND- WITH THAT HAPPEN
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND MOVE IT
UP. OR MAKE MOTION MOVING OUT
TODAY THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND. AND A
SECOND. THANK YOU. THREE HOURS.
YEAH SO- THANK YOU MISTER
MERRETT TO CHEAT. SO MY CONCERN
HERE IS THAT YOU KNOW LET BOTH
PARTIES ARE IN A BAD SITUATION
HERE- BOTH COMMERCIAL TENANTS
AND THE SMALL BUSINESS THAT IS
A COMMERCIAL LANDLORD AND THE
SMALL BUSINESS WHO IS A
COMMERCIAL TENANT- MY CONCERN
HERE IS YOU KNOW IT IS VERY BIG
AND THEY'RE ALWAYS TOLD AND LAW
SCHOOL YOU KNOW NEVER WRITE A
CONTRACT THAT SAYS TABLE
REASONABLY NEGOTIATE THE TERMS
OF THE NEXT CONTRACT BECAUSE
THERE'S REALLY NO WAY TO DEFINE
THAT- AND SO WHAT YOU OFTEN DO
AS YOU SAY HEY YOU KNOW YOU CAN
EITHER RE UP ON THE SAME TERMS-
YOU RIGHT EXACTLY THE SPECIFIC
TO. WANT SO THERE'S NOT THIS
PROBLEM LATER- AND SO WITH THAT
LANGUAGE IN THERE CURRENTLY AT
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
PROBLEMATIC REALLY FOR BOTH
SIDES BECAUSE HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE BOTH WHAT IS GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATION. AND THEN
WHAT'S A REASONABLE OPPORTUNITY
TO REPAY- AND I THINK THE
BETTER WAY TO DEAL WITH THIS IS
REALLY WHAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE
WHICH IS YOU KNOW AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE HAD PPP- THAT
DIDN'T NECESSARILY HELP A LOT
OF COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS.
ESPECIALLY SMALL MOM AND POPS
AND THAT'S WHO I'M REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT IS GOING TO GET.
HURT HERE THE SOPHISTICATED.
LARGE COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS ARE
GOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MANAGE THIS- WITH NO THEY HAVE
STAFF THEY HAVE ALL KINDS OF
PEOPLE MANAGING THESE
PROPERTIES. IS A SMALL MOM AND
POP LANDLORDS WHO'S ALREADY
BEEN OUT. THE MONEY. IT'S BEEN
STRUGGLING THROUGH THIS- THE
TENET IS ALSO STRUGGLE TO THIS
BUT- PROVIDING THE SUPPORT. THE
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS THAT WE
PASSED THIS YEAR IN ADDITION OF
THE FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S COME
IN THERE I THINK IT'S GOING TO
HELP THESE BUSINESSES. MAKE IT
THROUGH AND NATURALLY. IN THE
MARKET THIS IS WHAT'S GOING ON
ALREADY- I MEAN NO COMMERCIAL
LANDLORD REALLY WANTS TO LOSE
THEIR TENANTS. AND THEN HAVE TO
GO LOOK FOR ANOTHER ONE- IT'S
ONLY WHEN THERE'S JUST. WHEN
THIS IS JUST NOT GOING TO WORK
ANYMORE THAT. YOU KNOW THE
PARTIES MOVE ON- AND- I THINK
THIS COULD JUST ALTERNATELY.
YOU KNOW MARKET UP MORE FOR
THESE PARTIES RATHER THAN
REALLY PROVIDE THE CLARITY-
THAT THE MARKET AND THE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNMENT SUPPORT THAT'S
ALREADY COMING IN HAS HAS
PROVIDED. YEAH BUT I MEAN
PLEASE RESPOND TO YEAH WHATEVER
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE SURE I WILL
MISS YOU GALLAGHER YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T I DIDN'T FINISH THE
ORDER OF THE COIF LIKE YOU DID-
AND LAW SCHOOL BUT THAT YES I
DID I RECOGNIZE THAT- YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO TRY TO BE AS
SPECIFIC AS POSSIBLE- BUT I
THINK. YOU KNOW THAT THE BASIC
GOAL OF THIS BILL. YOU KNOW IS-
HAS TRIED TO ENCOURAGE GOOD
BEHAVIOR I MEAN. I THOUGHT THE
SAME THING AND I ASKED THESE.
ACTUAL REAL LIFE. SMALL
BUSINESSES YOU KNOW- IT WOULD
BE WHEN THE LANDLORD WANTS TO
NEGOTIATE WITH YOU SO THAT THEY
ONE HAVE A VACANCY SO THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE A- COMPLETE LOSS OF
REVENUES BUT- I WAS. I WAS
SURPRISED. AND EDUCATED-
REALIZING THAT THE- A GOOD
NUMBER YOU KNOW THIS IS SOME OF
THE WOULD SAY YEAH YOU KNOW.
OUR LANDLORD- GOOD NEGOTIATED
WORK WITH US- YOU KNOW
RECOGNIZING OUR HARDSHIPS. BUT
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED I MEAN
THERE. THERE THERE IS THERE WAS
ONE SITE VISIT IN IN TORRANCE
THAT I WENT TO WORK- THREE-
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND IN
THIS THE SAME- A COMMERCIAL-
STRIP MALL WAS- YOU KNOW THE-
TOLD ME THAT THEIR LANDLORD
REFUSED TO GIVE THEM ANY BREAK
AND SO. YOU KNOW I MEAN THIS IS
IN THE CONTEXT OF. OF OF- YOU
KNOW A LANDLORD FILING FOR A
UNLAWFUL DETAINER. YOU KNOW TO
MAKE THAT DECISION TO. TO HIRE
THE LAWYER TO FILED THE MOTION.
YOU KNOW TO- TWO TWO VICTOR
TENANTS- I THINK A LOT HAPPENS
BEFORE THAT I THINK WEEK IT'S
SAFE TO ASSUME THAT A LOT.
SHOULD HAPPEN BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT POINT BUT THIS BILL IS
JUST. PROVIDING THAT FURTHER
INCENTIVE YOU KNOW JUST A
LANDLORDS JUST MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'VE TRIED TO ENGAGE IN THIS
GOOD FAITH EFENSE. ARE IN GOOD
FAITH THAT NEGOTIATION
OTHERWISE. THE TENANT WOULD
HAVE THIS AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE
OF- THAT THE FAILURE TO DO WHAT
I THINK WE ALL AGREE SHOULD BE
DONE BY LANDLORDS ANYWAY. THANK
YOU DISTRESS. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU I THINK THAT FOR SOME
OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES- AND
FOR MANY OF OUR STAFF WHEN THEY
WOULD CALL AND SAY WHAT WHY DO
THEY WANT TO REJECT ME AND I
CAN'T PAY THE RENT- TO TELL
THEM WE TOOK CARE OF THE
RENTERS I'M SORRY WE DIDN'T
TAKE CARE OF THE COMMERCIAL
LEASES I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS FOR SOME OF
THE BUSINESSES I KNOW THEY WISH
THAT. THIS IT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR BUT THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING IT NOW I THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THE DETAILS
THAT ARE BEING REQUESTED I KNOW
YOU'RE WORKING ON THOSE AND YOU
COULD TELL FROM THE COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT TOO
WE WANTED TO BE A GOOD BILL BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE THE
PROTECTION FOR THOSE COMMERCIAL
RENTERS THAT. UNFORTUNATELY ARE
OR COULD HAVING TO CLOSE DOWN
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL
THANK YOU I CERTAINLY WOULD TO
YOU KNOW BE HONORED IF THE
MAJORITY LEADER WOULD ADD HER
NAME AS A CO AUTHOR I. I WOULD
BE HONORED IF THE ARCHITECT OF
THE AB THREE OH EIGHT WITH THAT
AS A CO AUTHOR AND ANYONE OF
YOU WOULD APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
YES I WOULD APPRECIATE BEING
NAMED AS ONE OF YOUR CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
RIGHT MR TO- RESEARCH OUT- I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TACKLING THIS ISSUE I HAVE A
LOT OF- RESTAURANTS IN MY TO
STREAK AND- WHO HAVE COMPLAINED
TO ME ABOUT THE SITUATION AND
DEVASTATED BY THIS PANDEMIC
OBVIOUSLY AND- YOU KNOW GRANTED
THAT THE WORD GOOD FAITH IS
SOMEWHAT NEBULOUS. WHEN IT
COMES TO. THE INTERPRETATION OF
IT BUT I THINK IF YOU COULD PUT
SOME GUARDRAILS AROUND IT OR
YOU KNOW FOR THE TO FIND OUT
TERM. I THINK IT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY AND- AND I THINK A LOT
OF MIGHT MIGHT YOU KNOW
CONSTITUENTS ACTUALLY HAVE.
BEEN SHUT DOWN JOE WAS SHUT
DOWN BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
AND I THINK THIS WILL WILL HELP
THEM- YOU KNOW. QUITE A BIT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL WEEK WE KNOW THAT- YOUR
DISTRICT HAS THE BEST CHINESE
FOOD IN THE WHOLE WORLD AND SO.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE
DON'T WE DON'T SHUT THEM DOWN.
I THINK YOU'VE JUST LOST A VOTE.
AND A CO AUTHOR SHIPMENT
FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT FOR THE COMMITTEE AND THEN
FOR THE AUTHOR GOOD FAITH DOES
HAVE. THE DEFINITION AND
CONTACTS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE UC SEEWE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LABOR LAW. COMMERCIAL PAPER.
IT'S PRETTY WELL ESTABLISHED
AND- I GUESS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY TRANSLATE HERE BUT
NOT NECESSARILY WHICH IS WHY
THE ANALYSIS ASKING FOR A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFICITY
OKAY. BUT IT BUT I THINK AS-
LAWYERS AND LAW STUDENTS TO
UNDERSTAND IN THOSE CONTACTS
WITH GOOD FAITH MEANS. ALL
RIGHT WE. DEMOCRATS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS I WILL NOTE ADDED
URGENCY CLAUSE TO AB TWO FIFTY
FIVE. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAO CHAO AYE CHU
CHU BY DAVIES DAVIES NOW
CONSOLIDATES GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES. RESIDE THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU WE NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX A. B. TWELVE FORTY
THREE THIS RUBIO. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION IS GOOD
MORNING RECKONS YES THANK YOU
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FORTY THREE
LEGISLATION THAT WILL EXPAND
THE ELDER ABUSE INDEPENDENT
ADULTS OF A PROTECTIONS ACT OR
E. A. D. ACPA. DUE TO THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC VISITATIONS TO
VULNERABLE GROUPS INCLUDING
ELDERLY INDIVIDUALS HAS BEEN
LIMITED. TO MINIMIZE EXPOSURE
TO EXPOSURE TO THE VIRUS FOR
MANY FAMILIES CARING FOR
RELATIVES IN COMMUNITY THIS
MEANT LITTLE OR NO VISITATIONS
OUTSIDE OF PRIMARY CARE A
PRIMARY CARE GIVERS. AB TWELVE
FORTY THREE WOULD PROVIDE WOULD
PROVIDE RECOURSE TO PREVENT AND
ADDRESS ISOLATION AFFORDABLE
CALIFORNIANS BY ALLOWING
INDIVIDUALS WITH PRE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS TO PETITION THE
COURT THROUGH THE EXISTING
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDER PROCESS.
AFTER NOTICING HEARING COURT
FINDINGS CAN BE USED TO ALLOW
CONTACT AND PREVENT ISOLATION
SO LONG AS THE ELDER OR
DEPENDENT ADULT BONTA CONTACT.
AB TWELVE FORTY THREE ALSO
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE REMEDY
FOR FINANCIAL ABUSE BY
EXTENDING. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN GLORIA FROM TWENTY
TWENTY. TO ALLOW JUDGE JUDGES
ISSUING ELDER AND DEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDERS
TO MAKE SIMILAR FINDINGS THAT'S
BEST THE SPECIFIC THAT. ARE THE
RESULT OF COURSE THAT. THIS
WILL GIVE THE PROTECTED PARTY
AN ADDITIONAL TOOL TO USE WHEN
FACING COLLECT THAT COLLECTION
ACTIVITY BY CREDITORS AND
COLLECTORS. THEY CAN USE THE
COURSE DEBT FINDINGS TO DISPUTE
DEBTS WITH CREDITORS COLLECTORS.
AND OUR CREDIT REPORTING AGENCY.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE- WILL WHICH
WILL PUT OUR FUTURE INCOME
FIVE. THEIR ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THE BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT WE PLAN
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
PARTNERS AND JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO MAKE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE IF NEED BE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE CHANGES
AND AMENDMENTS WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. ON THE LINE WITH
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FORTY THREE OUR FAITH
ABOUT AND DOWNEY- BECAUSE AMEND
THANK YOU THANK YOU I DO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES LISTED IN SUPPORT
ANY CAUSE OR MENTAL. AND FIFTH
THE BOOT. OTHER WITNESSES
AVAILABLE PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH
HELLO MY NEWSPAPER PRUDENT
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
I'M SPEAKING IN REGARDS TO AB
TWELVE FORTY THREE- I LIVE IN
MY CRESCENTA CALIFORNIA I'M THE
SISTER OF MY LATE BROTHER
MICHAEL DONOVAN WHO LIVED IN
WESTCHESTER CALIFORNIA I ALSO
HAVE TWO OLDER BROTHERS AND WE
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A VERY CLOSE
FAMILY FAMILY IS EVERYTHING TO
US MY BROTHER MIKE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH EARLY ONSET
DEMENTIA. AT AGE FIFTY EIGHT
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS AGO SINCE
HE WAS FIRST DIAGNOSED HIS WIFE
WOULD LIMIT HIS BUSINESS WITH
US YOU WOULD GO WEEKS WITHOUT
LETTING US HAVE CONTACT WITH
HIM SHE EVEN TOOK AWAY HIS CELL
PHONE SO THERE WAS NO WAY TO
DIRECTLY REACH HIM SHE ALSO CUT.
COMMUNICATION WORSENED AND WE
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT MIKE
MONDAY BISA DAUGHTERS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECALLED ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TO HAPPEN
CHECK MIKE SMOKING LISTEN REYES
MY LIFE AND FURTHER CONTACT WE
COULD ONLY SEE MY ONE THREE AND
PLACE FOR ONE AND COMPANIES ONE
OF FAMILY. EVERY TIME WE MAY
MICHAEL TELL US THAT WANTED TO
SEE IF MORE OFTEN AND VISIT
WITH US. WE TRY EVERYTHING TO
HELP OUR- WE HIS WIFE WE OUR-
FAMILY MEETING. AND EVEN REACH
OUT THE PRIEST MARRIED MY
CONTROL. MIKE'S WIFE. EVERY A
WE MAY. WE LOVE SAW MY IN LARGE
TO THE TWENTY WITH CAN ON
BECAUSE RIGHT BEFORE CO THAT.
WE COULD THE RAPIDITY. NUMBER
BROTHER. DI<c.cyan> CHO BUT HAPPEN</c>
SO WE OFFERED TO. WITH. WHEN I
CALLED HER BROTHER THAT I FOUND
OUT FROM HIM. THAT MY KID DIED
ON AUGUST TWENTY SECOND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. THIS WAS
UTTERLY HEARTBREAKING TO US
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
TAKE A BY. WE HOPE AND PRAY
THIS BILL PASSES SO THAT OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS WON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH BUT WE DID. AND ALSO A
TICKET ELDERS THE RIGHT TO TALK
AND BE WITH THE PEOPLE THAT A
LOT OF. FAMILY AND EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND IS
THERE ANY CARS REMAIN ON THE
LINE. YES GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU ARE A VOTE SHARE
NUMBERS. THAT STARTED LEGAL
SERVICES AS A NONPROFIT LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATION IN LOS ANGELES
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
TWELVE FORTY THREE. AND MY ROLE
AS AN ELDER JUSTICE STAFF
ATTORNEY I THINK PENTICTON FROM
ELDER ABUSE AND THEIR FAMILIES
EVERY DAY. IN TWENTY TWENTY
AXACT ELDER ABUSE RESTRAINING
ORDER CLINIC MATT WITH ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED LEAD AGAIN AND
EFFECTIVE AND FILING OVER. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY RESTRAINING
ORDER PETITION. AND STORY OF
ICE LIKE THE ONE THAT FACE SO
POWERFULLY SHARED ARE NOT
UNCOMMON. HOW DO I GET TEN
ADULTS WHO REGULARLY REPORT
BEING CUT OFF FROM THE US
BURNING CONTACTED FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS WITH HIM
THE DESIRE TO SEE. THAT
ADVOCATES CASE HER ISOLATED
FAMILY MEMBER HER BROTHER
COULDN'T REACH OUT TO ME FOR
HELP. AB TWELVE FORTY THREE
WOULD GET FAMILY MEMBERS LIKE
FAITH ANDOTHER PERSON CORRECT
PERSONAL PRE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS A PATHWAY TO HAVE
CONTACT WITH THE OWNER OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ISOLATED.
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDE
POLLUTION OUR INTAKE LINE IN
CLINIC ARE FULL OF FINANCIAL
ELDER ABUSE CASES. ONE FREQUENT
TYPE OF FINANCIAL ELDER ABUSE
IS COERCED THAT WERE
PERPETRATORS MISAPPROPRIATE A
LITERATE AND DEPENDENT ADULTS
CREDIT TO FRAUD OR UNDUE
INFLUENCE. FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
MY CLIENTS WITH MILD DEMENTIA
WAS DRIVEN TO HOURS FROM HER
HOME TO A CAR DEALERSHIP. WHERE
HE'S PERSUADED HER TO CO SIGN A
NEW CAR LOAN FOR HER. ALTHOUGH
THEY NEED COMMENTS TO MAKE ALL
THE MONTHLY PAYMENTS THE NEEDS
IMMEDIATELY PLEASE CALL SAID WE
THINK THE ELDER WITH THAT
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BURDEN.
AB TWELVE FORTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW JUDGES TO MAKE FINDING
THAT'S BECAUSE THE CATS ARE
COERCED AT TO HELP VICTIMS LIKE
MY CLIENT RECOVER FROM
FINANCIAL ABUSE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR IDOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE WHO LIKE TO SEE IN SOME OF
A TWELVE THREE. SEEING NONE THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEE NON
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE
FORTY THREE WE'RE NOT TAKING
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AT THIS
POINT JUST AS THE NAME
AFFILIATION AN INDICATION OF
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
SEVERAL OF FOR ONCE IT IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
PLACE. GOING TO GO TO LINE OF
FORTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FIFTY ONE. TEN
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE.
TWENTY BEGAN IN BOX HILL SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH JUST ME AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FORTY THREE THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO OFFER AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LINE FIFTY ONE
TO QUEUE UP AGAIN BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WERE LINE FIFTY ONE. FIVE
FIFTY ONE YEAR ONE SO BUT.
ANTIGONE ONE FIFTY THE CARD CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES. SORRY I
WOULD NEVER A BY THE NUMBERS
THAT WAS CONFUSING AND THE
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LI FERNANDE I'M A
TRAINEE PUBLIC LAWCENTER AND WE
ARE CLOSED FUND FAIR AND
OPERATES DRUNK THE PARK FOR A
BEACH ALL FORTY THREE. THANK
YOU. SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
COULD SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
OPPOSITION. WITNESSES LISTED SO
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE B. TWELVE FORTY
THREE. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE FORTY THREE. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NIKKI D.
OPERATOR WILL ANSWER YOUR LINE
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LUCKY
NUMBER WHICH WILL CALL UPON
YOU- WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT WHEN
WE'RE READY FOR YOU TO SPEAK.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NO WONDER SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MIKLOS ALLIANCE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PLEASE
DAVID. THIS RUBIO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS THIS
BILL AS- SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE A
LONG TIME AGO I'VE HAD MANY
FAMILIES SIT IN FRONT OF ME
GOING TO THE SAME THING AND
THEIR HANDS ARE TIED. AND I
COULD NEVER GET THEM ANSWERS OF
THIS WILL GIVE THEM WHAT THEY
NEED NOW SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THAT AND I WOULD BE HONORED TO
CO AUTHOR AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH F THE- US
DEPARTMENT EMOTIONS WE HAVEN'T
ALREADY. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THIS RACE. THANK
THANK YOU- MISTER YEOH THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT. BILL MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I AND MY
CONDOLENCES TO YOUR FIRST
WITNESS. WAS UNABLE TO. SEE HER
BROTHER. I CAN'T IMAGINE
ANYTHING. MORE HORRIBLE THAN
THAT. I THINK IT ALSO PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
FAMILIES. WHO ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THE CARE. THE MAJOR
PROTECTING THEM FROM SOMEBODY
TO COME IN- TO BE AND- INTER
MEDDLER- YEAH AND- SO THAT THEY
CAN'T LATER SAY WELL I WANTED
TO SPEAK WITH MY- UNCLE AND MY-
BROTHER. WHATEVER YOU HAVE YOU.
SO I THINK THE TOTAL
TRANSPARENCY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT SO I. APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR THE QUESTION
REMAINS SIGNALED HIS RUBIO YOU
MAY CLOSE THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. MOOSE'S DO
PASCHAL ROUGHLY. STONE HI STONE
HI GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
CHOW. CHAO AYE CHU. CHU AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA OUR AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES RAYSIDE
DOUBLES UP THANK YOU THANK YOU
THIS TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB FORTINO FIVE MS WICKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR TIME AND THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
WITH MANY CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING WITH THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF COVERED NINETEEN IT
IS IMPORTANT THERE ARE STRONG
PROTECTIONS TO PREVENT WELL
INTENTIONED BUT MISINFORM
CONSUMERS FROM FALLING TO WORSE
FINANCIAL SITUATIONS. THERE IS
CURRENTLY LITTLE TO NO
REGULATION DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT REFLECT
THE CHANGING PRACTICES OF THIS
INDUSTRY WHICH HAS MADE
ENFORCEMENT MORE DIFFICULT.
THIS LACK OF REGULATION HAS LED
TO INCREASED PREDATORY BEHAVIOR
BY SOME OF THE BAD ACTORS
WITHIN THE DEBT SETTLEMENT
INDUSTRY I ALSO WANNA SAY THERE
ARE MANY DOESN'T COMPANIES WERE
DOING VERY GOOD WORK FOR
CONSUMERS. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY CAN CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT BUT THIS BILLS AIMED AT
PROVIDING SOME REGULATION ON
THE BAD ACTORS TO ENSURE THAT
OUR CONSUMERS- ARE ARE LOOKED
AFTER AND CARED FOR NOT- FALL
VICTIM TO PREDATORY BEHAVIOR.
MOREOVER THE LACK OF REGULATION
OF THIS RING THE STREET HAS
RESULTED IN CONFUSION
FRUSTRATED CUSTOMER SPENDING
ADDITIONAL MONEY AND TIME.
TRYING TO DEAL WITH
UNANTICIPATED DEBT COLLECTION
LAWSUITS. OF THEIR AND ROLL
DEBTS. AB FORTINO FIVE WILL
MODERNIZE CURRENT LAW TO BETTER
REFLECT THE INDUSTRY'S
PRACTICES AND IMPROVE
REGULATION DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES IN THE FOLLOWING
WAYS. ONE IT WILL MAKE CLEAR
THAT ALL THAT SOME OF THE
COMPANY'S OPERATING CALIFORNIA
ARE COVERED BY CALIFORNIA LAW.
TO IT PROHIBITS DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES FROM ENGAGING IN
DECEPTIVE AND MISLEADING
PRACTICES. THREE IT REQUIRES
CRITICAL DISCLOSURES THAT WOULD
ALLOW CONSUMERS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
FINANCIAL OPTIONS AND LASTLY.
IT PROVIDES CONSUMERS. I INJURE
BY BAD ACTORS WITH REMEDIES.
THERE IS NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE
ACTION TO PROVIDE GUARDRAILS
BUDGET SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY
BEFORE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CONSUMERSWHO HAVE ALREADY OR
CURRENTLY SUFFERING THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC AND THIS RECESSION.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS AND A
SUPPLEMENT TO THE WORK OF THE
DF PI. WITH THE STATUS OF THE
PART IF HE ONLY HAS A BROAD
MANDATE TO REGULATE CONSUMERS
FOR THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS UNDER CALIFORNIA'S
FINANCIAL LAWS INCLUDING THE
REGULATION THAT SOME
INDUSTRIES. AB FORTINO FIVE
WILL SUPPLEMENT THE JFK'S
PURVIEW OVER THAT SOME
COMPANIES AND GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT TIME TO GROW
RESPONSIBLY WHILE PROVIDING
CONSUMERS WITH MORE ROBUST
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE URGENTLY
NEEDED NOW. WE'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND I
PLAN TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. WE'VE BET ON
MANY ZOOMS AND HAD MANY CALLS
AND I I'M I'M VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND SUPPORTED BY
NUMBER OF LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS AND CONSUMER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT WITH ME
TODAY ARE DESIREE WHEN OR IF
FROM THE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
PROJECT OF THE JUSTICE AND
DIVERSITY CENTER. OF THE BAR
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND ANNA DANNY KENDALL CRIES
ARE REPRESENTING THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES INDICATED BOTH ON THE
TELEPHONE DESIREE. NGUYEN WORTH
AND DANIELLE KENDO KAISER. GO
AHEAD IN EITHER ORDER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM LUXURY ONE
FOURTH PEOPLE LIKE ME TWENTY
FOR THE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
PROJECTS THE TOPIC NUMBER THREE
POINTER AT THE PARK AT LEAST A
SEPARATIST CAL SACRAMENTO BUT
PRACTICALLY BY A SETTLEMENT
COMPANY INJECTED FONG CRISTINA
CONSUMER AND QUIETER BUT THE
GOLD NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT OF
THE CONFLICT THAT PRESUMABLY
BUT NOT ALWAYS ONE OF NOT LESS
THAN WHAT IS OWED. AND THAT
GOVERNMENT CAN OPERATE BY
CONSUMER ENROLLMENT THAT WHICH
IS TO HAVE A LOOK AT WHAT SHE
DID NUMBER C<c.cyan> INTO ACCOUNT</c>
IN ORDER TO FIND THE RESULTANT
SETTLEMENTS NOW TO SEIZE
ELECTRONIC COMPANY THEN STOPPED
PAYMENT ON THE PAYMENT DATE IN
ORDER TO FORCE THE CREDITOR AND
NEGOTIATE SETTLEMENT AT THE
OUTSET OF THE PLAN AND ABOUT
THE TERMS TO CONSUMERS CREDIT
RATING IS A LARGE PART BECAUSE
THE CONSUMER GOODS FROM CURRENT
DEMOCRATS. AND EVENTUALLY TRY
GOT STATIC. NOTHING THAT I AM
DESCRIBING AVAILABLE TO THAT IT
COMES. CONSUMERS CAN BE ALLOWED
COMPILE TWENTY THREE. WHEN IT
COMES CONSUMER THAT A MARKET.
YOU'RE A LIKE THAT ARE
LIMITATION IMPOSED ON CREDITOR
WORKING WITH A DISTRICT NUMBERS.
THAT SADDAM AND IS NOT IT. IN
POINTS THAT. IT AFTER THE TRUE
THOUGH CONSUMERS OPTION TO DEAL
WITH TAX. BUT THE ONLY. THE ARE
HAVING OPTION AT ALL. YOUR
ABOUT WHAT THAT GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY IS. UNDER ISSUE. A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF IS THE
INCREASE OF CONNECTED IN WHEN
LAW THAT FROM THE- I A RESULT
OF. ADVERTISING YOUR GET A
CATEGORY AGREED SHOULD NOT BE
DOING THAT NOT FOR THE- BECAUSE
I THINK INCOME TO COMPLY. OF
THE COULD INTO AND I WOULD NOT
BECAUSE- AND ALONG THINKING IT
OVER I THINK THAT NINE. IT
MIGHT THIS COMPANY COMES UP THE
COST OF SENATE. SOME FOR GOING
MEDICALLY OR FOOD IN ORDER TO
STAY IN AND- GOT. PLAN IN.
CURRENTLY ALL THAT CONNECTS A
BY FOR RIGHT. AND MANY PRACTICE
ACT CHECK THE ACT. WILL BECOME
THAT HAVE LITTLE TO NO RIGHT.
AND CONSUMER HAVE NO. BECAUSE
OF THAT IT'S CAL COULD BE. OUT
OF THE THAT ON A. FORTINO FIVE
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS BE. HELLO
CONSUMER MORE. AND
OPPORTUNITIES MAKE AN EXTRA
CHOICE ABOUT MANAGING THEIR TAX.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
ITEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
THEN DANIELLE KIND OF CLOSER.
YES GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL KENDALL CARTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION A STATEWIDE
COALITION OF FORTY LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS I'D LIKE TO
READ A BRIEF POINT STORY FROM
BAY AREA LEGAL AID THE LARGEST
LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDER IN THE
BAY AREA. SHE STILL WORKS
MULTIPLE LOW WAGE JOBS SHE
STRUGGLE TO MAKE A MINIMUM
CREDIT CARD PAYMENTS. AFTER
SEARCHING FOR SOLUTIONS ONLINE
SHE RECEIVED AN EMAIL THE
SOLICITATION PROTEST SENTIMENT
SERVICES. DURING THE INITIAL
CALL A REPRESENTATIVE SAID THEY
WOULD TAKE CARE OF EVERYTHING
WITH HER CREDITORS. AFTER
MAKING PAYMENTS FOR ALMOST A
YEAR TO CELIA WAS SUED FOR AN
IN WORLD THAT. WHEN SHE
CONTACTED THE DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANY SHE WAS TOLD SHE COULD
SHE WOULD NOT THEY WOULD NOT
HELP HER TO RESPOND TO THE
LAWSUIT. UNLESS SHE INCREASED
HER MONTHLY PAYMENT WHICH SHE
COULD NOT AFFORD TO DO. AFTER
CANCELING THE CONTRACT AND
DESPITE HER CLASS. SHE NEVER
RECEIVED AN ACCOUNTING OR A
REFUND. SHE WAS LEFT WITH
DELINQUENT THAT MULTIPLE
COLLECTIONS LAWSUITS AND
ULTIMATELY SHE FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY. AB FORTINO FIVE
WILL NOT BAN THAT SETTLEMENT
AND IT WILL NOT RUN PIECE
COMPANIES OUT OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS PROVED BY THE FACT THE
DEBT SETTLEMENT SERVICES ARE
STILL OFFERED IN THE FORTY
THREE STATES THAT REGULATE THE
INDUSTRY. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONFLICT WITH THE D. S. P. I.'S
ABILITY TO REGULATE DEBT
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES. AND IN
FACT THE D. F. P. I WILL BE
ABLE TO ENFORCE FORTINO FIVE
ITSELF. NOR DOES THE BILL OVER
THIRTY COMPANIES ARE ALREADY
COMPLY WITH THE FTC'S
TELEMARKETING SALES ROLE.
BECAUSE MANY MANY OF THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THAT WILL. AB FORTINO FIVE
WILL GIVE CONSUMERS A CHANCE TO
MAKE AN INFORMED CHOICE IT
REQUIRES A COOLING OFF PERIOD
TO PREVENT FURTHER DAMAGE TO
CREDIT AND IT ALLOWS THE
CONSUMER TO DO MORE RESEARCH.
AND A PROHIBITS MISLEADING
ADVERTISING AND DECEPTIVE DEBT
SETTLEMENT PRACTICES. IN
CLOSING AB FORTINO FIVE
ENCOURAGES MARC MARKETPLACE
COMPETITION BY REQUIRING ALL
COMPANIES OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA. CAN COMPLY BY THE
SAME SET OF RULES. IT WILL
ENSURE THAT THAT SETTLEMENT
BECOMES A SAFER PRODUCT AND IT
WILL PROVIDE REMEDIES FOR
CONSUMERS INJURED BY BAD ACTORS.
BANKS LENDERS AND OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
VIEWED AS SAFE BECAUSE THEY ARE
WELL REGULATED. AS DEBT
SETTLEMENT BECOMES MORE
MAINSTREAM BETTER GUARDRAILS
WILL ACTUALLY GIVE CONSUMERS
BETTER OPTIONS TO MANAGE THEIR
TAX. I RESPECTFULLY URGE HER
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO
FIVE. SEEING THAT REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING THAT
WITNESS VIDEO WROTE. SEEING
NONE RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LIGHTS FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOURTEEN OH FIVE CAN
WERE TAKING NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISS
CHECK FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
M. AS CHAIR WE DO HAVE BY
SEVERAL FOR SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST
PERSON. LINE FIFTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS
DEFINITELY FARING WITH THE
PUBLIC LAST CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY PARKING
OUTSIDE. LINE SIXTY TWO.
MICHAEL BUS ATTORNEY WITH
PUBLIC COUNCIL I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
FIVE. BUYING. SIXTY SIX. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN YES.
I'M SORRY WHAT WAS BEHIND THE
NUMBER MY NAME IS PART GOING TO
REPRESENT THE FINANCIAL
COUNSELING ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
FOURTEEN OH FIVE IF AMENDED TO
INCLUDE APPROPRIATE
RESTRICTIONS PROTECT VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS. THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING-
CHARRON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KURT JOHNSON ROB I'M
WITH THE CONSUMER LAW CLINIC AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW AND BEHALF
OF OUR CLIENT I WANNA COME
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO FIVE. LINE MANGERS A
MOMENT. LINE THIRTY FIVE.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE COREY BUT
YOU'RE ON THE TELEPHONE AND
MARGARET CLASS DEAN ON THE
TELEPHONE. COREY BUTCHER. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND- CHAIRMAN STONE-
MY NAME IS COREY BUTCHER I AM
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF CONSUMER
DEBT RELIEF INITIATIVE. AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE UNIFORM DEBT
MANAGEMENT SERVICES ACT-
THERE'S BEEN ADOPTED BY MANY
STATES I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
STRONG PROPONENT OF GOOD
REGULATION AND OUR SPACE BUT AB
FOURTEEN OH FIVE MISSES THE
MARK. WE KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL HAS GOOD
INTENTIONS BUT THE TRUTH IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT IS AN
ETHICAL INDUSTRY. WITH NO
SYSTEMATIC ISSUES TO BE
ADDRESSED. THE CFPB'S TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT SHOWS THAT
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES ACCOUNT
FOUR. POINT 003% OF CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS. THAT'S A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE TOTAL
COMPLAINTS OUT OF OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
THOUSAND LAW LAST YEAR. AT
FOURTEEN OH FIVE DOES NOT
ENHANCE- PROTECTION FOR THE
CONSUMERS FROM DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES. BUT IN RETURN WOULD
HAVE GREAT CONSEQUENCES. THE
ONLY WAY OUR INDUSTRY WORKS IS
WE PROTECT AND ADVOCATE FOR
CONSUMERS. AND WE ARE ONLY
COMPENSATED IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL. THIS BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM
THAT SIMPLY DOESN'T EXIST.
FURTHERMORE AFTER A PANDEMIC
HAS DEVASTATED THE ECONOMY.
MANY CONSUMERS HAVE TAKEN ON
CREDIT CARD DEBT ABOUT.
MINORITY AND UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES WILL BE HIT THE
HARDEST. IF THIS BILL PASSES
THE WELL PEOPLE STILL HAVE
ACCESS TO GET SOME. BUT. LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES WILL NOT. I
ARE FROM THE STRUGGLING
CONSUMER. NOT JUST ON. IT'S
UNFAIR. FINALLY BILL WILL
ELIMINATE OR SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS FOR DEBT SETTLEMENT
PROVIDERS. IT WILL DRIVE MANY
SMALL PROVIDERS FROM THE MARKET
WHICH REDUCES CONSUMER CHOICE
AND PROTECTION. AS AN INDUSTRY
WE ADVOCATE FOR STRUGGLING
CONSUMERS AND WE HAVE A TRACK
RECORD TO PROVE IT. WE URGE A
NO VOTE ON EIGHTEEN AB FOURTEEN
O'CLOCK SO WE CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING VALUABLE. SERVICE
CITIES CONSUMERS WHO NEED IT
THE MOST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I WOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ASK.
THANK YOU MARGARET CLANCY.
MARKET QUESTION NUMBER HAPPY
AMERICAN FAIR CREDIT COUNCIL
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THEM THAT'S KIND
OF AN INDUSTRY WE ARE POSTAVY
FORTINO FIVE BETTERMENT OFFERS
TO HELP FINANCIAL DISTRESS
CONSUMERS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THE ANSWER SETTLED NEARLY HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS FOR DEBT MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS TYPICALLY SAVING
AND THIRTY FOUR CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR INCLUDING FEES. THE
SAVINGS ENABLE THEM TO GET BACK
ON THEIR FEET IN MANY CASES
AVOID BANKRUPTCY SETTLEMENT IS
GOVERNED BY A REGULATIONS
ESTABLISHED BY THE OBAMA ERA
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION AMONG
OTHER THINGS THOSE REGULATIONS
PROHIBIT PROVIDERS FROM
COLLECTING ANY FEES UNTIL THEY
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY NEGOTIATE
WITH THE CREDITOR THE CONSUMER
HAS ACCEPTED THAT NEGOTIATION
AND THEN HAD MADE A PAYMENT TO
THE CREDITOR ALSO UNDER THESE
RULES THAT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES
ARE PROHIBITED FROM TOUCHING OR
CONTROLLING CONSUMER FUNDS.
CONSUMERS CAN LEAVE THE PROGRAM
AT ANY TIME AT NO ADDITIONAL
COST IF HE IS NOT OPPOSED TO
STATE OVERSIGHT LAST YEAR WE
OFFER LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE STATE LICENSING FOR THE
INDUSTRY THIS YEAR HOWEVER WE
QUESTION THE NEED FOR THE BILL
AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND BASS WHICH
CREATED AND GIVEN. AT THE TO
REGULATE THAT SET THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INCLUDED
EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION FOR
THIS NEW DOLLARS FOR THE FORTY
AND THIS YEAR NINE POINT 19% A
PAST IF THERE IS LEGISLATION WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS ARE
PREPARING TRANSPARENCY AND
SHARE HER GOAL MAKING SURE
CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
WORKS HOWEVER AB FORTINO FIVE
TO PAINT MULTIPLE ON WHAT WILL
PROVISIONS FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL
REQUIRES US TO REFUND CONSUMERS
MONEY WITHIN THREE DAYS IF THEY
CANCEL CONTRACT. AS STATED
ABOVE WE NEVER TOUCH CONSUMER
FUNDS THEREFORE THERE'S NOTHING
PRESS THREE FOR THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT TO DESCRIBE
SPECIFIC TAX CONSEQUENCES BUT
WE AREN'T LAWYERS OR
ACCOUNTANTS THEREFORE WE CANNOT
GIVE TAX ADVICE WE HAVE SHARED
AMENDMENTS WITH THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS THESE AND OTHER ISSUES
WE'VE ALSO ADDED DISCLOSURES
THAT ARE MORE CONSUMER
PERSPECTIVE THAN THOSE
CURRENTLY FOUND IN AB FORTINO
FIVE. YES THE AUTHOR TO ACCEPT.
OUR CHANGES AND MOVE THIS INTO
THE FINANCIAL AT THAT FOR A FOR
A CLARIFIED ESPN RESPONSE. IN
ITS OF BROUGHT CONSUMER
PROTECTION. KILL THAT HAVE. AFP
REMAIN OPPOSED TO A BEFORE
FIVE. WE ARE HELLO COMMITTED TO
WORKING THE AUTHOR ATTEMPT. OUR
IN A PRE HER WILL. TO WORK WITH
THAT. WE DON'T FEEL LIKE THE-
THANK THE COMMITTEE THEIR THIRD.
ANALYSIS AND THEIR TIME TO
SPEND WITH US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIRTY ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTINO FIVE.
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SEEING NONE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING RIGHT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
FORTINO FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO DO CARE WE
DO HAVE- PEOPLE WHO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WITH A
GO TO LINE SIXTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS NAMELY
PETRON ON BEHALF OF SINCERITY
AND RESPECT OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FOURTEEN OH FIVE THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
PERSON. LINE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAROLINE WILL
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL
DEBT RELIEF ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE THAT THEY DON'T
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. RIGHT
THANK YOU BECAUSE THE LINES OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS GONZALEZ. AM I DON'T KNOW
IF THE GENTLEMAN IN OPPOSITION
THE CONSUMER DEBT RELIEF
INITIATIVE IF HE'S STILL THERE.
IS RICHARD WELL I AM. I'D LIKE
TO KNOW- YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
THE EMAIL. TELLING ME THAT THIS
IS GONNA HURT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
ORGANIZED IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR MY ENTIRE LIFE I JUST.
LIKE SOME CLARIFICATION- THE
ECONOMIC JUSTICE FIRST IS THAT
A GROUP IN EXISTENCE OF.
OUTSIDE OF THIS INITIATIVE
BECAUSE I SPENT SOME TIME
TRYING TO FIND THEM AND ALL I
FIND IS THAT THE- HEAD OF THAT
WAS A FORMER. MARIBEL SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS HOW MANY MEMBERS
THAT GROUP HAS. AS FAR AS THE
EQUAL JUSTICE- MEMBERS I THINK
IT'S CALLED ACCORDING TO YOU
THE ECONOMIC JUSTICE FIRST. YOU
SUBMITTED A LETTER OPPOSITION
FROM THEM- YES I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY WHAT THEIR
MEMBER COUNTY IS- YOU KNOW I DO
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE SUPPORTED
US IN SUPPORT OF OUR GENDER-
AND I WOULD I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU WITH THE EXACT NUMBERS OF
HOW MANY MEMBERS THEY HAVE YEAH
THAT BE GREAT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T APPEAR TO HAVE ANY.
ONLINE PRESENCE OR PRESENCE
BEYOND- THE GENTLEMAN WHO
SIGNED THE LETTER I'M ALSO
RESOURCE A COALITION OF SMALL
RETAILERS LOOK AT ZACHARY. IS
HE THE- ARIZONA GOP COMMUNITY.
STAR I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE IF HE IS WITH THE GOP IN
ARIZONA- ONCE AGAIN IT IS A
ANOTHER GROUP THAT HAS
SUPPORTED OUR INITIATIVE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AT SEVERAL GROUPS
THAT ARE SUPPORTING OUR
INITIATIVE- SURE YOU KNOW
TOWARDS WHAT WE STAND FOR THE
SENATE CONSUMER DEBT RELIEF
INITIATIVE SIR I'M JUST
OFFENDED WHEN I CONTINUE TO GET
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION FROM FAKE
GROUPS. THAT ARE ESTABLISHED
SIMPLY TO SUGGEST THAT MINORITY
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE HURT BY
ANY BILL THIS IS NOT THE FIRST-
BUT I JUST WANT THIS TO BE
NOTICED THAT I WILL RESEARCH
THESE I LOOK FORWARD TO KNOW A
YOUR EXPLANATION OF THESE
GROUPS AND IN PERHAPS PERHAPS
IN FUTURE WE CAN HAVE HONEST
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW THIS
AFFECTS COMMUNITIES AND NOT BE
SENT LETTERS FROM THE ARIZONA
GOP COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
SUGGESTING THAT THEIR SUPPORT
THEIR US SOMEHOW REPRESENTING
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT I I'M SORRY
I'M OF THIS BILL I'M JUST
REALLY TIRED OF. THIS TYPE OF-
THANK OPPOSITION THANK YOU YOUR
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND. AND
THE SECOND THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THIS ADDRESS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I ALSO HAD A QUESTION
FOR MR BUTCHER. IN YOUR
COMMENTS YOU SAID THIS THIS
PROPOSAL FOR DEBT SETTLEMENT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
DEBT SETTLEMENT. I'M SORRY THE
DEBT SETTLEMENT WILL REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR THE RICH BUT NOT
FOR THE POOR. AND YET IN THE
ANALYSIS IT SAYS THAT THIS BILL
IS MEANT TO ADDRESS THE ABUSIVE
PRACTICES WITHIN THE DEBT
SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY. I WANTED
TO KNOW HOW IT IS THAT YOU
FELT. THAT DEBT SETTLEMENT
WOULD REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR THE
RICH BUT NOT FOR THE POOR. IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION- SO OBVIOUSLY DEBT
SETTLEMENT- HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES AND DECADES I BET
SOMEONE INDUSTRY ONE AND THEN
IT YOU KNOW I DID SOME OF THE
WRITERS- WITH PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LARGER INCOME ARE LARGER
BALLOTS IS. THERE TO DO WOULD
BE TO GO HIRE AN ATTORNEY-
INTAKE TURNINGS YOU KNOW
ANYWHERE FROM THREE HUNDRED TO
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR AGO REPRESENTING TO THE
CREDITORS- AND- LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES THEY DON'T HAVE
THAT. THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
OFFER- I WOULD WANT TO SAY WHEN
YOU LISTEN TO ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE IN OPPOSITION IT WAS
FIRMS OR- RELATED TO LEGAL
SERVICES- WE- YOU KNOW. WHAT
WHAT THAT THAT IS AN OPTION
THAT IS AN EXPENSIVE OPTION.
THAT UNFORTUNATELY IT CONSUMER
GOODS AND FINANCIAL DISTRESS
JUST DOESN'T HAVE THAT OPTION-
WITH WITH THAT SETTLEMENT- WE
CAN GET EVERYBODY WE HAVE. WE
HAVE HIGH INCOME EARNERS ARE
HIGH DEBT LOAD WE HAVE. ONE
GENERAL LOWER DEBT LOAD I THINK
THAT. THE MISCONCEPTION THAT
THAT WAS PRESENTED EARLIER IS
THAT WE YOU KNOW TARGET ELDERLY
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER THAT COMES INTO DEBT
SETTLEMENT PROGRAM. IS FIFTY
TWO YEARS OLD. ALSO IT SAYS YOU
KNOW THAT THIS HURTS THEIR
CREDIT. IT DOESN'T THAT THE
AVERAGE CONSUMER THAT COMES
INTO THIS PROGRAM ON AVERAGE IS
A SIX TWENTY CREDIT SCORE. OR
CREDIT HAS ALREADY BEEN HARD.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S THERE'S A
LOT OF MISCONCEPTIONS OUT
THERE. ABOUT WHAT THAT SOMEONE
PROVIDERS DO. BUT AS FAR AS THE
ELIMINATING FOR THOSE
STRUGGLING CONSUMERS THAT- ARE
IN THE LOWER INCOME. BRACKET
THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE LEGAL
SERVICES OR THE ABILITY OR THE
MONEY TO ACCESS. OF THESE
ATTORNEYS- THAT COULD DO THAT
SETTLEMENT FOR THEM. SO THEY
HAVE TO COME TO A PROVIDER LIKE
OURSELVES. THAT CAN CAN OFFER
THE SERVICES- TO THOSE
CONSUMERS. THEN FOR. THE THOSE
WHO SERVE. OUR SERVICES FOR
DEBT. SETTLEMENT TO AVAILABLE
TO THOSE WHO CANNOT AFFORD AN
ATTORNEY. SO THAT WAS A
QUESTION FOR ME. I'M SORRY FOR
EITHER DANIEL BECAUSE WHO
DESIREE NGUYEN NORTH. WHY HI
YES. SO SETTLEMENT SERVICE AND
MY EXPERIENCE I WHAT DO I WITH
YOUR I LOW INCOME NOT THE BAY
AREA AND IN MY EXPERIENCE
PUBLIC SERVICES HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE TO ALL OF MY AMERICA-
PRIMARILY LOW INCOME PRIMARILY
ELDERLY PEOPLE- FOLKS WHO
RECEIVE PROTECTED IN CALIFORNIA
DOES WELL IT'S QUITE IN THE
COMING TERM BUT PEOPLE WHO HAS.
BEEN ACCEPTED INTO GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU COULD YOU
PLEASE YOUR- YES CALGARY WHEN
LIFE BY THE ATTORNEY FOR THE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY PROJECTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THAT WAS
MY EXPERIENCE HAVING
VOLUNTEERED WITH THE LEGAL AID
FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS THAT IS
DEBT SETTLEMENT SERVICES WERE
AVAILABLE TO THOSE WHO COULD
NOT AFFORD AN ATTORNEY I ALSO
WANTED TO COMMENT THAT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM IS
GLAD STEAM. AND THE WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO TRY
TO MAKE THIS THE BEST BILL
POSSIBLE AND IN THE END DOING
EXACTLY AS IT PURPORTS TO DO
AND THAT'S TO ADDRESS THE
ABUSIVE PRACTICES WITHIN THE
DEBT SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR PRESENTING
THIS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS WAS
GALLAGHER. YEAH I THINK THE
CONCERN HERE IS THAT THIS IS A
SERVICE THAT IS HELPING A LOT
OF PEOPLE I MEAN WE HAVE
CERTAINLY A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
GONE INTO DEBT EVEN BEFORE CO
THAT THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT
HAPPEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC- NO
BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING THAT'S
TRANSPIRED- AND YEAH THIS IS AN
INDUSTRY THAT. IS HELPING
PEOPLE. IT'S NOT EASY TO BE
CALLING CREDIT CARD COMPANIES
DIFFERENT. GROUPS TO TRY AND
RESOLVE DEBT SETTLEMENT SO WE
HAVE SOMEONE OUT IN THE MARKET
IS PROVIDING A SERVICE THAT. I
THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING DOES
HELP A LOT OF CONSUMERS RIGHT
ARE THE BAD ACTORS OF COURSE
THERE ARE. THEY ARE IN ALMOST
EVERY INDUSTRY- BUT LOOK I
THINK HAT WHAT WHAT THE
CONCERN IS THAT THIS MIGHT.
HAMPER THE SERVICE BEING
PROVIDED- TO CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND- NOW IT LOOKS
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IS NOT A FAKE GROUP-
AND THEY OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR
THAT VERY REASON- IS THAT THEY
WANT TO SEE THAT THAT THE
SERVICE IS NOT UNDULY HAMPERED-
SO. I THINK. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE MAYBE. I MEAN HAVE
YOU CONSIDERED PERHAPS TAKING
OUT THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
BECAUSE TO ME THAT JUST SEEMS
LIKE IT OPENS THE DOOR TO.
ADDITIONAL LAWSUITS OVER THIS
ONE REALLY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO IS SAY HEY LOOK CONSUMERS
SHOULD HAVE NOTICE- THAT'S THE
BASIC PREMISE OF YOUR BILLS TO
PROVIDE THIS NOTICE TO
CONSUMERS SO THEY CAN MAKE
DECISIONS- TOLD ME ABOUT THIS
AND EVEN GET OUT OF THAT. THIS
CONTRACT IF IT IF THEY
DETERMINE THAT THESE. THINGS
HAVE NOT BEEN MET. IS THAT
RIGHT AND MAYBE YOU CAN RESPOND
TO THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO GO AT THIS IS
CERTAINLY I THINK A GOOD THING.
BUT IF PEOPLE KNOW HEY THERE'S
GONNA BE PRIVATE RIGHTS OF
ACTION FOR. ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING THEY MIGHT WITHDRAW
FROM. THE FIELD AND THAT PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED THAT. I THINK BY AND
LARGE A LOT OF PEOPLE. FEEL
LIKE IT'S A POSITIVE THING.
HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE REMARKS.
MR- SO THERE'S ANOTHER ARE DOT
COM COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
GOOD WORK FOR CONSUMERS AND
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDST OF
COVERED RECOVERY WE'D WE NEED
THAT THERE ARE ALSO BAD ACTORS
AND ARE LEGALLY CLINICS ARE
SEEING AND FEELING AND HEARING
IN DEALING WITH THOSE ALL THE
TIME RIGHT I ALSO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT THAT-
THERE'S BEEN VERY FEW
COMPLAINTS TO CONSUMER NOT JUST
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU.
THERE'S LOW REPORTING BECAUSE
THERE ACTUALLY ISN'T A SECTION
FOR DEBT SETTLEMENT COMPLAINTS
RIGHT AND SO I THINK IT'S VERY
UNDER REPORTED IN TERMS OF
REPORTS TO CFPB BUT WE'RE
SEEING IT WITHIN OUR LEGAL AID
CLINICS AND SO THE GOAL OF THIS
BILLS TO TIGHTEN THE
REGULATIONS AROUND THIS TO
ENSURE THAT THE GOOD ACTORS ARE
DOING THE GOOD WORK IN THE BAD
ACTORS ARE BEING DEALT WITH
ACCORDINGLY AND PART OF BEING
DEALT WITH IS PROVIDING- APPEAR
REYES TO THE CONSUMERS HAVE
SOME ABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH RECOURSE WHEN THEY
NEEDED RIGHT AND YOU KNOW DO
YOU HAVE GUYS GETTING SET UP
IT'S A THREE YEAR RUN WAY IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME FOR
THEM THEY'RE DOING WITH LARGER
POLICY ISSUES- WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE FBI AND THEIR
PURVIEW OVER THE SPACE BUT ALSO
FEEL LIKE THE PIER A GIVES US
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
DEAL WITH THOSE BAD ACTORS. I
THINK ONE THING THE- GUYS THAT
THE MORE THINGS. THERE'S ALSO A
FEE SHIFTING PROVISION WITHIN
THE PIER RIGHT SO IF THERE'S
SOME SORT OF MERITLESS LAWSUITS
THE FEES COME BACK ON THE
CONSUMERS IF THEIR MERITLESS
RIGHT SO THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF PROVISION THERE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT YOU
RAISE. THAT I THINK DO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF GUARD RAILS SO THAT
WE WON'T HAVE THE SORT OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT'S
WHERE I WAS GOING TO GO NOT TO
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO YOUR
TAKEN TODAY RIGHT YEP- AND I
THINK THAT'S INTERESTING I
THINK WE SHOULD APPLY THAT IN
OTHER. AREAS AS WELL LIKE IF
SOMEONE IS BRING IN A MERITLESS
ACTION THAT THE ATTORNEYS FEES
SHOULD. ALSO APPLY ON THE OTHER
SIDE WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT MANY
OTHER AREAS BUT I THINK THAT
THAT THAT DOES HELP I THINK
THAT DOES HELP THE SITUATION.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT ALSO I
MEAN WE'VE DONE THIS BEFORE
ANOTHER BILLS IS MAKE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THE
ONE WHO ENFORCES WHAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW THE I. NOW RIGHT SO
THERE'S WE HAVE A NEW
REGULATORY AGENCY AROUND THIS
BUT I THINK IT'S- YOU NOW
THEY'RE STILL. GET THEIR SEA
LEGS RIGHT AND I THINK WE'RE
DEALING WITH- A SITUATION RIGHT
NOW TODAY WE HAVE. MANY
CONSUMERS LOW INCOME CONSUMERS
DISBURSING CONSUMERS HAVE COLOR
RIGHT WHO ARE DEALING WITH SOME
OF THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF THE
BAD ACTORS WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE THEM A TOOL AND WORKING
WITH ARE LEGALLY. CLINICS WHO
DO SERVE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
I KNOW YOU MAY I RESPOND AS-
WELL. OKAY NOW. NO YOU MAY NOT.
I KNOW THAT YOU. CARE ABOUT
THAT THE QUESTION WAS ADDRESSED
IN THE OUT APOLOGIZE NO WAS NOT.
I KNOW THE AUTHOR DOES DO A LOT
OF GOOD WORK WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION SO I WILL PARTY SAID
I JUST IF WE DON'T WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES BECAUSE I.
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO UNDULY
HAMPER- A SERVICE THAT THAT
MANY CONSUMERS TO FIND HELPFUL
ABSOLUTELY AND WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS YOU KNOW
I WORK ON THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR
AS WELL AND ANOTHER BILL-
MARGARET AND I ARE ON SPEED
DIAL WITH EACH OTHER. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SO- BUT I ALSO
DON'T WANT TO LOSE SIGHT OF THE
OVERALL GOAL OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING YOU KNOW
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
CONSUMERS WHO. NEED THESE
PROTECTIONS. FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT CA NINETY SIX I
DO APPRECIATE THE- YOUR BILL
AND I'VE I THINK. THE RIGHT
RIGHT OF ACTION IS VERY
IMPORTANT HERE BECAUSE WHETHER
C. TOURNEY GENERAL OR THE- THE
NEW AGENCY THEY THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE LIMITED BANDWIDTH AND THAT
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IS WHAT
GIVES AN AGGRIEVED PERSON IN
THIS CASE. ACCESS TO JUSTICE
OTHERWISE THEY CAN'T HAPPEN AND
WE DID DO THE FEE SHIFTING HERE
WHICH I AM. RETICENT TO DO IN
MOST OF THESE CASES ESPECIALLY
WITH LOW INCOME PEOPLE. BECAUSE
THEY'RE TOO EASILY INTIMIDATED
BY THE THREAT. OF HAVING TO
POTENTIALLY PAY LEGAL FEES AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BRING A
CASE UNDER THAT THREAT THAT IS
A BAD ACTION IT IS. PROBABLY AN
ILLEGAL ACTIONS AT LEAST
UNETHICAL BUT WE KNOW THAT IT
HAPPENS AND SO FEE SHIFTING IS
ABOUT ACCESS TO JUSTICE THAT WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL WHEN WE
ARE CONSIDERING. THOSE
PROVISIONS BUT I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE THAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE AND THAT YOU'RE
STANDING UP FOR CONSUMERS. AND
WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE AM I
APPRECIATED APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS THE POINTS THAT
ARE MADE ON THE DíAS THE
QUESTIONS AROUND THE PUREE-
GONZALEZ IS AN MISS RACES
POINTS AS WELL. ALSO JUST CLOSE
AND SAY THAT FORTY THREE STATES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA REGULATE
THAT SALMAN INDUSTRY NINE OF
ACTUALLY BANNED THE PRACTICE
COMPLETELY- SO OUR GOAL IS TO
CREATE REGULATION HERE THAT
HELPS CONSUMERS AND DEALS WITH
ABOUT ACTORS BUT DOING SO IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY SO. WITHOUT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CALDERON
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHOW CHOW HI CHU CHU
AYE DAVIES DAVIES NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I RAISE
RAISE I. THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT
LOOKS LIKE OKAY EVERYBODY ELSE
IS HERE SO LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH THE AGENDA TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN ADD ON WELL
BILLS HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE SO LET'S GO BACK
AND START WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA. I CONSENT CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CONSENT
GALLAGHER. I'M CONSENT.
GALLAGHER I CHU CHU I. HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B. SEVEN FORTY SIX SIRVENTES
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHU CHU
HI HOLDEN HOLDEN I MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION I. THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE FIFTY
EIGHT FLORA GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIN CHINA THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB ELEVEN A ONE.
IRWIN CHU CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I AM
NUMBER FOUR AB TEN SIXTY TWO
MATHIS CHU CHU I. HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHENNAI. I
REMEMBER FIVE AB TWO FIFTY FIVE
MATTEUCCI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. BUT OF NUMBER
SIX AB TWELVE FORTY THREE RUBIO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
REMEMBER SEVEN I THINK WE HAVE
EVERYONE. WE DO ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
TODAY THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
AND WE ARE A JERK.